come on
oh yeah that's the one right now
and you know that yeah
right now it's going to be late today
yeah that's okay
she's over there yeah or in Fruit Street
okay
these are hearing so we can just pump
ahead here
every day
no what's an interesting choice
you've been there recently and I can't
remember what I was all with
memory laptops
foreign
good morning everybody I trust everybody
he's got those eyes wide open this
morning and either very happy over the
Chiefs winning are very sad that the
Eagles didn't win
um so
have fun with it uh write the first we
have a number of hearings this morning
it looks like we have six hearings this
morning so with that I'd like to get on
with the first one uh that's dealing
with HP 204 represent Belcher is the
prime sponsor of this bill it's an act
relative to non-academic surveys in
schools and representative Belcher
welcome
thank you and good morning chairman Ladd
and honorable members of the committee
so this bill is
is quite simple but we'll get into it
and we'll see that it may not be that
simple but it is still quite simple
so I've only added a few words to
existing law
when it comes to non-academic surveys
that are prohibited
I have clarified that it doesn't matter
whether it's physical or digital just to
make sure that's very clear
and I've added one more category which
is emotional responses
now the reason I've done that is because
as I was campaigning for this job
and speaking to a lot of constituents
and attending a lot of meetings I heard
from a lot of concerned parents that
they are were questions being posed to
them on various tests and surveys and
whatnot in their schools that were
probing into how their children felt
about certain things
and they thought that was inappropriate
they felt that the the idea that you're
when you leave the three R's as we call
it and we start getting into feelings
and how children feel about things we're
getting away from education and we're
moving into the field of psychology
because that is where feelings and
emotions are properly dealt with
and I think we all know that that
um the teachers are not generally
trained psychologists and generally
speaking I don't think they want to be
practicing psychology on children so
there was a genuine concern about things
that were actually happening I was able
to see some of the questions that they
were referring to they brought them to
my attention so these are real things
that are occurring in New Hampshire
schools
um
so then there's the other track which
then this gets into a little bit more
theoretical but it's extremely important
to understand and it gets into some
really cutting-edge stuff
so as we all know technology is becoming
more important every day not just in our
lives but in schools they're using
technology as an adjunct to help teach
children constantly
now some of the stuff they're doing and
some of the stuff that is happening
right now
relies on
you could call it a form of manipulation
it's actually something known
technically as nudge theory if you were
to do a simple Google search for nudge
Theory Academia or nudge theory in
education you would find a Litany of
Education articles and academic Journal
papers
advising how
by obtaining something of a
psychological profile of a student
through understanding their emotional
responses to certain things
they can actually plug that information
into Cutting Edge
algorithmically driven artificial
intelligence programs that are being
offered up through some of these
education programs
um some of them come in the forms of
digital friends that students
communicate with through their computers
or devices
and through nudge Theory what they're
actually able to do is apply a very
subtle behavioral modification
and a lot of a lot of it is designed not
simply to stop you know anti-social or
bad behaviors but to actually inculcate
and indoctrinate into values-based items
that are very controversial
and items for political debate and
discussion and not things that should
Simply Be
pushed on the students without parents
knowledge or permission
and with that I'd be happy to take
questions thank you very much are there
questions of Representative yes
representative Myler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
representative Belcher
we have
seen in this committee
this session
Expressions concerned about the mental
health of students
it's a big problem and we'll all have
acknowledge that
with your language here of not being
able to check the emotional part of it
how do schools begin to identify the
mental health
of students so that the appropriate
Services can be provided to them to help
them out thank you well thank you very
much for the question and I think that
that goes to the fundamental question
that we're looking at here because I
would I would assert that
the educational environment of a school
is not the appropriate place to be
screening or administering Mental Health
on children that is not an appropriate
environment the teachers are not trained
for that
that is the primary responsibility of
parents obviously when when something
out of the norm is detected it's
perfectly acceptable to communicate with
parents to move forward with what the
parents would like to direct for mental
health treatment but schools are not um
they're not facilities from they're not
medical facilities they're education
facilities
yes representative Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question
do you
do you think that public education
should be a safety net for children
can you expound a little bit I'm not
exactly sure what you mean so we know
that you know Public Schools
teach at C around 150 000 students in in
New Hampshire a year in the year
and out of those hundred and fifty
thousand there's a significant number of
them who have situations
um where they don't have a terrific
um
parents
or or adults to go back to to to guide
them to help them uh to feed them to
clothe them to offer safety to them
sometimes it's just the opposite and the
school district
um
provides a safety net for that for
abused children for homeless children
for Hungry children for children that
are having having difficulties and
um it seems that to me that what you're
saying is we should just ignore that
absolutely not abusive and neglectful
behavior is abhorrent and absolutely I
believe I generally speaking almost
anybody is a mandated reporter in this
state and I think that obviously
um whenever necessary and appropriate
contact to medical professionals and
um and law enforcement is totally
necessary and that's something I had to
do often as a paramedic when I was
working unfortunately I found some very
difficult situations
yes you may
so how do you know
I mean in in a lot of instances kids are
really good at hiding issues like that
and they they're very afraid and if they
don't talk to you and they don't there
isn't an emotional interchange where
they're you're talking about that how do
you expect that that schools can can be
that kind of safety net for students
that's what I that's what I mean sure
thank you and I I would go in two
different directions with that first of
all I would say the bill itself
um if it clarifies this that it's
talking about surveys physical or
digital so we're not talking about you
know having one-on-one conversations or
a teacher getting to know their student
and having a relationship there
um the other direction I would go to
answer that question is that
and I've lost it
um
I'm sorry maybe it'll come back to me
further questions yes representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so
tell me how
uh privacy goes on these surveys I mean
either
there's no way to determine what
particular child has a particular
problem or there is a violation of
privacy how do you draw that what that
final question that's a very good point
if if you're if you're going to be
removing identifying information
obviously from surveys such as I believe
the CDC survey that I forget what it's
called it's on here I believe that does
that so that doesn't offer the
opportunity to individually Target
students for any kind of intervention
the best you could probably do is uh is
community or some other Collective based
Intervention which is not particularly
useful like it doesn't seem
um
so that's a that's a very good question
um there would be no way to remove the
individual identifying information from
a survey
um in order to protect Privacy
Information and still be able to Target
a student
who was demonstrating any sort of
um mental health issues and so it would
have to be a non-private situation
um and that and whether that information
is stored in a local manner or a far
away server that could also be a
considerable concern we know that a lot
of the the companies that
um that are applying this kind of
Technology especially with the digital
surveys
they do have off-site servers they may
not even be located in this country
further questions representative Damon
and then representative woodcock
excuse me thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
following up on your answer to
representative drive's question
it sounds to me that you're
acknowledging and correct me if I'm not
hearing this accurately
that
surveys gather aggregate data
so therefore if that's true
surveying a population of students in
regards to
their report
of their well-being including emotional
well-being
would not violate anyone's privacy or
safety it would simply be a better
understanding
of the status of the say 10 year old
population or whatever group is being
surveyed
thank you and I'd be happy to clarify so
I believe surveys can obviously be
engineered in multiple ways you can have
surveys that do remove identifying
information such as I believe the CDC
survey that can therefore then be used
for other kinds of like I say
collective-based intervention
um
but there are also surveys that are
individual that are given in class every
day that may even be attached to
academic instruction
and such as tests that begin to probe
into information that is
feelings based or is based on things in
your household that could have
personally identifiable information
attached to it and further when you
begin to attach the digital component of
it that again this is Cutting Edge stuff
that stuff is designed to be
individualistic that stuff is designed
to feed into an artificial intelligence
model that is going to approach an
individual child in an individualized
way in order to apply these algorithms
um
so that's obviously not at all private
as far as
yes
could you cite some resources for
what you just said because honestly I'm
not on the same page and I'd like to
understand where
where's the data that this is happening
where is it published sure
um well if you were to Google
um I believe the phrase is nudge Theory
education I believe one of the first two
or three links that's going to come up
is an article from the journal Ed week
which is a major education Journal
publication that talks about how they're
incorporating these um these
Technologies into the classroom there's
also as I said a whole Litany of
academic literature there's other major
education journals major Publications
articles to this effect that will get
into the details of nudge Theory and
algorithmically driven artificial
intelligence and artificial friends that
children can interact with in some of
these programs that
and how it's designed to again affect
behavioral changes and outcomes
yes
and do those resources you just cited
document this is happening to our New
Hampshire students I'm highly skeptical
that's a very good question I don't have
a survey of everything that's going on
in New Hampshire I do know that some of
the larger companies such as amplify do
have their their toes in the water I
could say on this sort of thing I don't
know exactly what's been deployed across
the state in every District
representative Woodcock did you have
your hand up
I did a few minutes ago thank you
um
thank you
president I'm following up on I wasn't
following up on but I am now on on the
question I just asked you up
you made a statements that sure is given
I think it said in classroom survey to
give it to classrooms every day
uh and sometimes including for academic
destruction that's what you say if
they're wrote it down
um
this is a school district policy
teachers typically don't start creating
individual surveys and individual things
for students so I I don't understand
that that connection of in the classroom
every single day for instruction
that that being said the you can clarify
that for me the second part is the
and I understand the analytics of the
future world uh but these surveys uh
typically the ones I've been involved
with over the years uh disaggregate the
data of a group so you can find out and
Target certain areas of say instruction
or say education or say uh this this
part of the region has difficult issues
with uh
we're gonna say the bomb down there or
an explosion say the school like a
school had had an issue okay where they
made it in a bomb or a killing or
something so that they tied to the whole
state they see that wow we need to bring
in some intervention because we find all
the kids are actually aren't responding
as well as their thoughts for those
things
um but there's a lot of people but uh
where have you have you seen the survey
the teachers just give out every day
like this I mean this does it seems like
that's
but you think these come out willy-nilly
I mean they have to be all the preceding
pieces to this legislation they're in
they're in law right now deal with the
structures you're aware of parents are
on the website
um so I I don't know where you're sure
you're coming from with this okay I'm
gonna try to pull all the pieces out of
that so I can try to build a picture
um
so as far as my statement that this is
happening in an everyday context it's
it's due to some of the stuff that I was
brought by some of my constituents and
as I was speaking with them that some
some such things that are probing into
emotional responses such as how students
feel about certain things they're part
of everyday
um quizzing and testing that is
occurring
um per these constituents and they
showed me some of the documentation of
this so that is what I meant when it
came to that
um as far as the disaggregated data and
targeting I believe that's the reason
that we left the CDC one alone but I
would however go back to the the sort of
foundational principle here which is
that
fundamentally schools are not places of
mental health treatment they are places
of Education
um and because they're not equipped
like a mental health treatment center
when you administer some of these things
to students when you start playing with
psychological
algorithms or whether it's probing
questions you can cause
um certain harms mentally and schools
are not necessarily prepared to deal
with that teachers are not necessarily
prepared to deal with that that is
better left to a a proper professional
and a proper environment I believe
representative for did you have your
hand up yes I did
with apologies for my English prop
background
I would
I would like to pose the question
is there something inherent in
asking you know how you feel about
something rather than what do you think
about that
um thank you that's an interesting
question so to clarify first ask nothing
in the bill would prohibit a teacher
asking this is referring to
physical and digital surveys and
questionnaires and stuff like that
um so if you're next to your actual
question whether there's a difference
between feel
and um believe was or thing and think
um
that is a much more complicated question
we can get into the sort of
um epistemological question of whether
a feelings based
subjective view of the world versus an
objective view of the world where you're
using rationality versus it goes back to
Russo's Romanticism versus locks
important rationality often have factual
reasons
for one and you have emotional reasons
for the other I believe that's correct
yes
thank you represent Allison well thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh could you share with us what
are some of the specific questions that
were on the surveys that your
constituents objected to I mean I'm
trying to try to tie this down a little
bit sure thank you and I I can give you
sort of my best remembrance I don't
quote me on the exact thing but they
were there were items such as
um
they were sometimes they would begin
with a question about uh this family can
afford to do this thing but this family
can't afford to do this thing and it
could be a math sort of thing but then
it kind of trails off from the math part
into well how do we feel about this
family that couldn't afford to do this
thing and what do we think maybe ought
to be done about that and what are your
feelings on it and and we're we're going
down in this context we were taking a
math problem from a math class and kind
of going in a in strange
uh social Direction in a strange
Direction probing into feelings and
emotions uh that the that in that case
my constituent felt was inappropriate
follow-up yes sir uh in so the first
part of your response in terms of the
the example of two families with
whatever
um
and and that's a math problem then
specifically on this survey it then said
how do you feel about this situation I
mean is that what you're you're saying
to us yes it was something don't quote
me on the exact language but it was to
that effect the context is correct
thank you I do have a question I haven't
asked one yet
um I'm looking at the U.S risk behavior
survey and it's designed to elicit
information from students yes and
there's a question right here I'd like
you to respond to
that in the youth risk behavior survey
uh 23 New Hampshire
during the past 12 months how many times
did someone you were dating or going out
with purposely tried to control you or
emotionally hurt you
my question is are we getting Beyond
asking part here and getting into the
thinking or what you know about this
emotionally hurting a person is that a
question that might be reconsidered how
this is asked in the survey
um just as regards to that CDC survey
I'm not a personally a big fan of it
being administered without strict
permission
um if I thought I could do that with
this and have a chance of it getting
past I probably would have crafted the
bill that way as far as that specific
question
um how do they feel about that
when you get into the psychological
context when you're actually trying to
elicit psychological information that's
in a perfectly appropriate question and
it is I think perhaps going to lead you
down a path that a psychologist a
trained professional would go down in
order to begin affecting a course of
treatment and Care toward helping
somebody
um but that's not what's happening in a
school environment when those questions
asked if you disaggregate the
information you have no access to the
person
all you're getting is data which may or
may not be correct we've heard that it
probably is but it doesn't actually do
much to help that person and that
environment I don't think is appropriate
for it
thank you
further questions representative Damon
would you agree that it is important for
students
people in general
to be able to identify and label their
emotions
that's a little bit of a difficult
question identify can you can you be a
little more specific when you need to
identify and label as in what what in
particular
um so a for instance would be
a student might be physically acting out
say stopping their feet or you know some
physical manifestation of something
and a teacher might say
what's going on here
and perhaps that student would say I'm
very angry or I'm very frustrated or
so that would be
what I'm saying is that student
are they able to identify and label the
emotion that is driving their behavior
okay thank you I appreciate the
clarification I think
I think I would have to answer whether
or not they can understand the
appropriateness of the emotion and
regulate it internally is going to be
far more important than whether they can
put a label to it but I could I suppose
there would be certain utility in being
able to put a label to it
oh yes
perhaps if I could ask you to focus more
on the capacity of the student to
identify their emotion
not worry about the terminology but that
they
I mean it's tied together
it sounds more like the kind of thing
you might do sitting on a couch than a
classroom
for further questions
um do we have any other pink cards or
I'm just trying to get a handle on that
we only had this one from the presenter
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
um
I'd like to bring to the table reality
in a public school setting because of my
experiences uh for so long and I really
am just trying to share information for
people who aren't aware of what really
goes on
um situation I just like to get a feel
for it by the way I think we have a
minimum standard or a law that requires
us to do social emotional learning
within our schools
um so I don't know if you're aware of
that there are screenings that that are
used for that
but an example
so I was a principal of three schools K
to four
and every morning I was greeted by a
student who was as tall as I was who
called me an F MF or every morning
now the school counselor was in Bartlett
School and the school nurse was immersed
in school
and so
under those circumstances would a nudge
theorist call the police firsthand
for being called a name
every day every day upon entry
I don't know that that would
qualify necessarily as a actionable
criminal offense that seems like
more of a school discipline action I
mean when I was in school if you did
that you would you would be suspended
and that seemed to work out pretty well
for the most part well it turned out to
be a student that was special needs and
behaviors learned
it they don't come to school they don't
learn it at school it's learned at home
and so it took over a month to change
the effect of that student
to understand that whatever he was
bringing to school from home needed to
change his affect and so if we weren't
able to process or if I wasn't able to
work with that student every single day
to process
that even if you're his mother you know
whatever happened when he got dropped
off it wasn't okay for him to express
his anger coming through the door so it
really wasn't a discipline issue for
school it was a matter of unchanging
behavior my question yes he answered
well yes I asked him if he would call
the police about that because he
mentioned that okay she would call the
police so that's it so he responded Yes
yep that's it thanks for their questions
may I just responded that real quick
since I think there was a little bit of
a question there
I would just say that
I'm glad that the situation worked out
as such but I don't think you can draw a
conclusion that because one methodology
was successful another methodology would
not have been successful that would be a
logical fallacy so it very well I'm not
saying it would have but it may have
been solved through discipline as well
further questions yes represent Balboni
um I just have a question thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um I just have are you making any
distinct it seems like you're
distinguishing between oral versus
written or digital so say if I was a
teacher in uh second grade and I had a
circle and I was curious about the mood
of my students that day and I had them
just take out a pen and pencil and write
down how are you feeling today would you
consider that a survey
no I think it's very clear that physical
or digital would not consider that I
think that was done on purpose because
we understand that humans have human
relationships and that includes teachers
and students and I don't think that's
something that we would seek to to
prohibit or alter or do anything to we
the idea is to prohibit intrusive
written and digital surveys that would
be inappropriate I believe in the school
setting
um and Lead toward
items that are not also not appropriate
such as the application of nudge Theory
or other psychological psychologizing in
the classroom
yes follow up um would that also apply
to like self-service say if you were in
a class and you were taking us given a
set of questions that you answered that
were only for your own use they were put
out there as part of an assignment and
That You Did in the class but we're not
necessarily shared they were part of a
self-identification process
yes there would be no exception for for
that
any further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you very much
we need to turn off the red
a little confusing
we have a few moment is there anybody
here from Health and Human Services that
could answer something regarding youth
risk behavior survey as a technical
question which I do have one
welcome you've been here many times
um it is a card filled so why don't you
just pass it around so that we can have
that
foreign
my question for you is that the the
question I read here is where I'd like
to start is during the past 12 months
how many times did someone you were
dating or going out with purposely try
to control you or emotionally hurt you
my question is I know this information's
disaggregated
is there
any availability of information where a
particular region or a school has a
whole
that has a lot more than just 10 kids
kids in it is informed that you have a
very high incidence of something such as
this occurring so that the school can
turn around and use it in supporting and
assisting or helping
um in this regard
thank you chairman lad again for the
record my name is Abby Rogers
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health Services
for the record my name is
public health statistic emblematic in
the division of Public Health Services
so to answer the question I think they
focus on how School uses data more
specifically on this type of question
um did I get that right well if a
question comes back is there any way of
determining that
um
School District X has a high response in
regard to this particular question where
it happened five or six times at least
and where they've had this emotional
you know
um issue that they're dealing with uh
how how does that data help
the district that's you know part of
this survey when it's all disaggregated
and may come back in the form for the
state as a whole
it's just like we're doing mathematics
we're trying to find out where we're
hurting in math and we're trying to
disaggregate that information down so we
find out there's the issue right there
how do you do that with this survey so
for the so many data that we do today
are aggregated uh depends on the regions
and we have the state level data we have
the Public Health Region data we also
have school district data so for the
Public Health Region as well as state
level data those are publicly available
and we look into by demographic area uh
like a gender
um grades not agebook grades and
sometimes if a data supports or data
balance is enough we will also look into
raising ethnicity but that's very
um
um the major race in New Hampshire it is
white so so for the other races we
probably don't do not have that type of
data to support that depends on the
response rate for the specific question
or for the specific Topic in terms of
how School utilize the data or the
superintendent uh intendants they get
their own school district report in this
in the school district report that they
can look into the time trend on the same
questions asking
year by year by year and then for that
way they will be able to see how the
trends all the response for this
specific questions how students um
reported themselves whether they got
hurt or based on the question that you
you just mentioned whether the trends
goes up for the specific schools or
whether the train goes down or where the
train keeps the same in that way I
believe the school can utilize their own
resource to go to the focus area that
they would like to help with the
students
thank you that that that's good to hear
that but the next question I would have
is this information you provide to the
local school or School District
available to the public
no excuse me no photo School
specifically report they are not
available to the public for several
reasons the first reason is that the
school report are not weighted so we are
not able to provide the information on
the statistical meaning to identify this
school is doing better or worse
comparing to the Public Health Region or
the state level what do we encourage in
the school to look into the report is to
look into their own school
performance compared to the time Trend
compared to the specific Geographic
excuse me demographic group like male
female over by grades to see if there's
some kind of outstanding for example
this type of question may impact a
certain group of students in their
schools that's what we encourage the
school to utilize the report and focus
on the particular group in order to put
some resource into that group so in in
just my last follow-up on that so the
school district is aware
but in order to try and we we know that
education is a partnership between the
the home life the parent the schools
Etc
how are we going to ever correct
something if the school district doesn't
communicate these results to the parent
or the community
I don't think I'm in a good position to
answer that because that would be a part
of the program
um prevention uh whether it's in the
school level District level or in the
state level my position can provide the
um you know getting information how
school will utilize the data but how
schools actually utilize the data that's
the part of information I do not have
but we are happy to get other folks from
Bureau of drug and alcohol services or
other like in injury prevention programs
um crisis center Etc to provide more
information how school work with them to
utilize the data on their specific
School District thank you very much for
answering those questions through Santa
Luna
thank you very much Mr chair and uh and
a follow-up actually to um to your your
questions here oftentimes when when this
committee has heard uh a bill relative
to um to a non-academic survey or maybe
even more specifically the um the youth
risk behavior survey
um um
people from other organizations such as
um Chief David Goldstein from Franklin
would uh would be in attendance to
testify as to the importance of of that
Anonymous data that applies directly to
the community that his Department serves
and I do know from my time of school
board that school boards do receive
maybe not as detailed a report as the
one you're talking about but I think
there is the trend data as you've
suggested I was wondering if you could
um talk a little bit too and I think
this goes to um to represent vlad's
question how other community service
organizations might be able to use some
of this data and why it's so important
to them
thank you and since we have the state
level and also Public Health Region so
for the Public Health Region we identify
13 Public Health Reaching Across the
states is finer than the county level so
for political Health Region data is
available some communities they utilize
Public Health Region data for example
like a greater National or greater
Manchester to identify you know the
trend and also the particular
demographic groups in in their region or
in their Network in terms of the schools
it will up to the school board or the
superintendent particularly how the
schools would like to distribute the
report to Their audience so some schools
are very open what I observed to share
the school level data over District
level data with the school board or even
post down their own website some schools
um on the other way they you know they
they perform the elements to the schools
but uh they may just keep it in in their
own like a school counselors for them to
be able to utilize the data so I cannot
speak for how schools uh they use the
data currently but we do encourage the
schools to look into the data uh look at
the trends for each um questions if it's
comparable Time After Time and also
focus on uh some Trends if there is some
kind of like a data point that goes up
particularly in 2021 which we have seen
in the preliminary data that mental
health is a concern for 2021 data
compared to other years those are the
areas that the schools will do encourage
schools to look into the data and then
work with the local communities or even
the state program areas to uh allocate
the resources order to provide some
support to students on on the need
so that open up another question for me
and then represent so you see some
schools share the data
some schools choose not to maybe share
it with the counselors
is there any
I guess from what I'm hearing you there
isn't I guess any kind of statutory
language or federal language that says
you cannot share this with the community
you I'm sorry
I can try to rephrase that
why are some schools sharing this and
communicating the disaggregated
information to the public and others not
I
yeah
thank you uh I think I could I can try
to answer that I think uh my
understanding is some schools do share
it you know publicly on their website to
inform Community Partners of the health
of their schools others may may make
that decision internally to share it
just internally I think it depends on
the school district and I certainly
we're not kind of well advanced in the
knowledge of who shares what but
certainly the yrbs data is used
widespread in New Hampshire through
Community organizations to inform all
sorts of measures for tobacco use
Suicide Prevention domestic violence
prevention
um uh chronic disease prevention for HIV
obesity substance abuse I mean it's it's
really the biggest measure to the health
of the school population I'm not
questioning those categories I'm I'm
looking at how this information is used
to assist
the community and dealing with some of
these concerns right sure so the way why
RBS data is is used to inform program
planning in the community certainly at
the state level
um and you know identify indicators
where a certain Community needs to be
able to go to provide some prevention
for those issues represent Woodcock did
you have a question a very quick one
thank you and as a follow-up to
representative lad it's thinking
actually someone was thinking when
you're talking about trending and
surveys and data points uh you mentioned
recently just about the mental health
issues obviously came post uh the
pandemic uh does DHS
DHHS or uh in conjunction with doe do
either of you provide to school
communities potential programs or
options how to help when you see
trending data going in negative uh trend
thank you for the question so we do have
a like what Abby address we do have
enjoyed prevention programs and also
crisis centers that works with the um
the schools and as well as the public
health regions
um they work with the schools very
closely to look into the data on their
original data and if the superintendents
also provide the data to the network
they also look into the data together as
well in terms of some services that we
provide in the school reported that we
uh relates to the superintendent we do
put some program information like a
crisis center or the Public Health
Region who they can contact you if they
have any questions
regarding the particular question not
the data question but particular you
know how they queue response to this
kind of Trend in their schools we do
provide that type of contact information
in the report the radius to the
superintendents as well thank you
chairman thank you very much are the
further quite representative Miler thank
you Mr church just to clarification what
you're saying
um
one of the issues that was pointed out
in the testimony was a concern that
schools are not really there to provide
emotional issues that they're there to
just teach the three r's my presumption
isn't to clarify this for me if there is
an issue
that's a that's an emotional issue
that's identified in the survey
that school then would then refer that
issue
to a professional be it a school
counselor social worker somebody from
your office perhaps but it would not
necessarily be a teacher but it'd be
somebody who would be trained in dealing
with that particular issue that was
identified in the response of the survey
is that correct
I do not have uh and so for that
question because that will fall under
how School operate over a Provider
Services
um you know for us we provided the data
that after the survey and then also
provide some kind of support how to read
the data for example and if there's a
need we also connect the schools with
other resources from the state agencies
if they would like to look for more
information but whether uh it would be a
particular teacher or a trend a social
worker Consular for example to help the
student that will fall under the school
operation thank you very much
representative Tanner
I just want to make make sure because it
with the questioning it sounds almost
like
some people think that the school gets
individual results these are still
aggregate results that the School
receives not individual in other words
they would not know that
Sally Jones got hurt in a
relationship emotionally hurt in a
relationship they the trend and the
trend and the aggregate data is all
treated as statistics not as individuals
is that am I right on that that is car
access Court does not receive the raw
data they receive the aggregate report
that has owed the 9th to 12th graders
who responded to the questions or
participated in the surveys that report
is all aggregate data and there is no
identified to see which class this
record is from over
um you know we which
um
classroom old classical teacher's name
is not available on the data or the
report that superintendents receive
yes
so when you receive if aggregate data
whether you're a Mental Health
institution or a school
area
would that would it logically seem as
though the the re the
or The Logical result of that is that
they would Institute programs that would
be in general for the population that
they're dealing with that might have it
an exceptionally High abuse or emotional
abuse station rather than
um
again individual training uh you know
targeted to a very small group
thank you for the question yes indeed
like it would be generally uh the data
would inform the school Community uh
like Trends in the school Community
which then also could be
representational of perhaps a broader
Community concern uh so that that is
correct
are those are the further questions
thank you very much oh yes I just want
to provide more information related to
the school report the county that we
provide in the school is not the actual
number of students who answer the
question with the implemented uh the
couch uh that the respondent count to
the actual enrollment number so it's
kind of like a projection so it's not
actually you know five students answer
this question that means only five
students who took the survey on that day
answer the question that is also
increment um and Modified by the um
enrollment number to be able to provide
a more General and more aggregate level
on the data thank you
thank you very much
I did receive one of the card
which does not take any position as
offering any kind of technical support
we may want on this it's Becky Wilson
from the school boards Association does
anybody have questions for the school
boards Association
Becky
good morning good morning for the record
Becky Wilson from the New Hampshire
school boards Association I heard a
number of questions I think most of them
have been answered but I'm happy to
answer any other questions about how
these results are shared was through
school boards Etc in the public thank
you representative Tanner thank you
thank you for taking my question and
coming up
um I'm concerned with
what we keep hearing that the teachers
are not psychologists that um you know
were that even counselors aren't
training trained in mental health and I
wonder if
school boards have kind of a policy
where
there's a delineation
certainly for teachers of signs and
symptoms that then get sent to a higher
level of of
um
a profession that's within the school
and
um the school psychologists the school
social worker maybe the special
education teacher
uh thank you for the question I will do
my best I think to address your concerns
so
it's important to note that part of the
minimum standards and part of the
Staffing that is required as a result of
the minimum standards requires schools
to have certain people with certain
licenses and certain certifications
those people are teachers school
counselors School psychologists School
social workers Etc not all of those
positions are mandated necessarily but
each of them carry with them a certain
criteria that you need to meet in order
to become licensed to do that job those
are not the kinds of jobs where people
are on alternative plans necessarily or
are doing them with you know other kinds
of oversight those are very specific
positions
schools have processes for determining
individual student need and who is
referred to what person or what
department based on those needs and I
would a share that I believe for the
most part most schools have a threshold
for lack of a better term of what is a
school-related education related mental
health need and what goes beyond that
and schools have very specific processes
about when they refer out so to speak
with parents uh to get more services for
students who may need more services
there are not necessarily
psychologist services that you're
receiving at the school level is not
necessarily the same psychologist
Services you are going to receive in a
mental health center in your community
that a parent is taking a child to to
address concerns School psychologists
for the most part in public schools are
providing education evaluations as part
of a special ed process for example or
something to that effect so certainly
not every school has access to all of
those positions either either due to
funding or due to Geographics that
there's just not those kinds of people
in all of those schools so there are
many schools that contract out with
local providers for certain services but
again they're educationally based Mental
Health Services and just to clarify and
I think reiterate what was already said
School level data from the yrbs comes
back to the school for a very particular
purpose and that is to make sure that
your high schools are understanding
their kind of current
group of students that are in their
schools and what their needs may be as a
whole and that information at least from
my own experience is shared at a school
board meeting with the school board in
somewhat of a scrubbed manner for lack
of a better term because depending on
the size of your school how many high
schools you have if it's just one and
it's small you want to make sure again
that even though you're not getting
individual student data that you're
presenting that in a public forum where
everybody has that information but it's
protecting students and families
personal privacy if there are not a lot
of students in your school
um
thank you representative cascadden thank
you Mr chair
um thank you Becky I was just curious if
you are aware whether School staffs are
still undergoing the youth Mental Health
First Aid course thank you for the
question yes a Justice Broderick has
been presenting at multiple high schools
throughout the state for many many years
he continues to provide mental health
youth first aid survey first aid
training and as part of Dartmouth
Hitchcock's initiative schools ask them
to come and do those trainings for
students and that is to help other
students help each other it is about
making sure that kids understand what
other kids needs may be and to try to
support each other that is not
necessarily simply about staff
identifying those things it's really
about creating peer relationships that
are supportive in that way thank you
not see any other questions thank you
very much you're welcome
with that we'll close this hearing
and March on to HB 550 this is relative
to Charter Public School disillusion
550.
foreign
welcome representative fellows
morning good morning
um let's see
I have written testimony for this bill
but I didn't have an opportunity to make
25 copies yet so I will bring them uh
down right after we finish during this
spill so every charter school has a
dissolution provision that spells out
what will happen when any assets
remaining after they resolve all
financial obligations
and there have been at least start six
charter schools that have closed and had
to go through this process so this is
not you know just an academic
um exercise here yeah uh I wondered what
happened to those assets of the six
charter schools that closed and and
there's no information about that on the
web but there is information on the web
about the current Charter Schools you
can access all of their Charters and you
can read this particular provision so I
didn't look at them all but I looked at
10 of them
and all seem to give the charter school
board the sole Authority about making
decisions of
um what happens to remaining assets when
they close
several charter schools and these this
is what I found so several Charter
Schools provided two options to the
board either give assets and money to
another Charter School
or to a non-profit that supports charter
schools and in this in all cases it was
never specified
which particular charter school or which
particular non-profit agency
one one that I looked at said all
remaining assets could go to any
501c3 which is any non-profit
organization one said
remaining assets could go to any 501 3C
or
to the federal state or local government
for educational purposes
one said that donated property and or
the proceeds from the sale of those
donated items would be returned to the
donor
and
proceeds from the sale of items
purchased with Federal
or state grants would be returned to the
states so one thing you can see here is
there's many different options going on
um I think some of those options are
problematic when you make a donation to
a 501 3C I don't think that you can get
the money back again I think if you
particularly if you used it for uh don't
you know a deduction on your income
filing
uh let's see
let's see
um another concern I had is that it's
it's fairly easy to set up a 501 3C
so I'm concerned that
um someone related to the school in some
way could set up a 501 3C and then the
school could give the assets or the
proceeds to that particular
um
5013c and you know that just doesn't
sound that's not a
um doesn't sound like a good process to
go through
I also this is my opinion but I think
that
um we should consider requiring
um
any remaining assets
that didn't have a particular provision
related to
the donation of that item that those
General
um
remaining assets should go back to the
state because the state has paid for the
vast majority of the operating costs of
that school so that would be an
appropriate way to treat them but that's
just my opinion
um
so these these concerns led me to file
an an LSR and if you look at the bill
the first section of the LSR is was my
attempt to write a standardized
uh revision to the dissolution provision
that has to be in their Charter
but after that happened I had a meeting
with
um
some people from Department of Education
and administrative Services who had
concerns about
how this would work and in the um in
that meeting other issues were also
identified the biggest one being that
the Department of Justice has a division
for charitable organizations that they
oversee
and charter schools because they are all
501c3
um have provisions
that govern them for being a non-profit
but we also have state laws that govern
what happens to them because they are
also a public school
and I think that we've got some
conflicts going on between those two and
it would be useful to call together all
the people that are involved with that
could they could be involved with this
and
um give them opportunity to identify
um a process that would work for
everyone
so I asked for the LSR to be redrafted
and it was late in the game because this
LSR actually got lost in the system and
so what you have here is
the section one is what I first proposed
in section two is what I asked for a
redraft so I would hope that you would
um
not I hope that you would pass this bill
just as section two
so there's eliminate one and just
um
proceed with section two
and I think I I also
um when I met with with the
depart somebody from
um Department of administration of
services and people from doe they also
identified that there are some issues
that are really not Financial that they
would like to work on and
um
one of those was mentioned was Student
Records what happens to the Student
Records when a charter school closed I
don't think there's any
statute that covers that and an ongoing
problem which I can tell you from
even back when when I was at the
Department of Education which was more
than five years ago now that it has
always been a concern about the ability
of some of the charter schools to really
manage their Finance as well
and they don't have the um some of them
don't have the same level of expertise
that you would see in a public school
so
it would be
useful to give some discussion in
consideration to
maybe new requirements that have to do
with financial management internal
controls of of charter schools in terms
of their financial management because
the advantage of that would be that we
could identify what schools were in
trouble before they get to the point
where they maybe will have to dissolve
or dissolve in when they are financially
insolvent
because that's creates that's the
biggest issue and an example of that
having happened was the capital city
charter schools which my impression is
that that's still not entirely resolved
so I hope you will approve
the section
about the charter committee
because what it will do is it will be an
opportunity to provide transparency
accountability and clear guidance for
the disposal of Charter School assets
that were purchased with State funds
it will make it possible to identify
Financial instability before it becomes
Financial insolvency
and it will also have be an opportunity
to identify ways to minimize the
disruption to Charter School students
and staff when a school closes
there are some
minor Corrections that are needed
for the committee
section
the Quorum number has to be changed
because it the way it's
uh worded right now every single member
would have to be there to have a quorum
so that's not necessary and needs to be
fixed and
um
I don't have a specific
recommendation
for the due date I don't know if on
December 15th
would be reasonable or it should be
extended so
that's the end of my testimony I'll take
any questions thank you very much
representative are there any questions
representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question okay so I was thrown
off because I was looking at the wrong
number two like as Point number two in
your italics but you actually mean the
whole section that goes down to where it
starts committee is that correct yes so
so on the first page just get rid of
lines one through
16. okay and just have it start on 17
that's the two that's section two of the
bill okay follow up please yes thank you
and uh
then at this point all the dissolution
things that are in charter schools
charters for example are still in effect
and there's nothing that that works on
those this is just a committee
well one of the things that is really
complicated that I ran into is you know
I my impression from the Meet the
meeting that I had which included Sherry
brockburn who's the Deputy Commissioner
at administrative services and
um to people from Department of
Education Sherry rodburn said that
um
the the charitable
division
that is resp now I forgot your question
what was your question
do the things that charter schools have
written as their dissolution policies
right now remain in effect yeah yes well
yes because they're there in in
um that's a requirement that's published
but they might not be like really legal
if they if they were questioned and the
biggest issue that I can see is that the
regulations related to 501c3s
are not aligned with the regulations
that are in State Statute the rsas
that say you can just you know write
your dissolution provision and
the the things that they wrote may not
really
comply with the 501c3 requirements or
either that or they don't comply with
state requirements so
that's a problem that's that's a big
part of the problem but the the other
it's also important that maybe we can
work out some way that there is warning
when a school is going to have to close
I mean you don't want to like you know
Christmas break during Christmas break
you found out that the schools insolvent
and they're not going to open up in
January we need to have warning of that
okay I'll follow up with this thing
thank you so it's my understanding that
the Char charitable trust handles these
they also handle the papers that 501c3's
file when they're there so they would
have caught something if they were
looking at their filing papers so are
you planning to work with the charitable
trust division as well
the if you look in here if you look in
the bill it says that it requires
a line on the first page line 29
that a representative of the charitable
trust division from the Department of
Education the Department of Justice
excuse me
um
has to be available to the
the committee okay thank you very much
further questions representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative fellows for
bringing this
um a very important
um uh matter to uh to our attention
um and and you've you've you've clearly
um
done quite a bit of work uh including
meetings with administrative Services uh
Department of Ed uh education and um and
um
I believe it's is it still um um uh
attorney general Donovan over at
charitable trust no uh I I so we do have
charitable trust we have the director
here thank you thank you very much
because and and
um in the in the in the past Rick I'd
worked with um with um uh General
Donovan on um on a number of statutes
involving the merger and acquisition and
disposition of of um non-profit
hospitals in New Hampshire and clearly
this is a very significant
um uh and very complex area in the law
and so uh so
um it was really more of a more of a
comment than a um than a question but my
question to you Sally would be
could you could you provide us with um
with the the amount I know it's not very
complicated deleting section one but uh
but you know if we have um if we have
support from administrative Services as
well as Department of Justice as well as
the Department of Education in um in
addressing this very complex portion of
the law maybe there's a chance that um
that is that a study
um you know could be done to uh to
properly
um you know document what the
requirements are for um um you know for
these um for these schools uh in the
event of dissolution
so the question part was can you can you
provide us with uh with the amendment
that I think one of us would be happy
I don't think I can because I think that
to get to what you need uh I mean as
opposed I suppose if somebody could ask
um
Department of Education and
administrative services and the chair
will trust to to get together and have a
meeting in in one or two meetings if
they could come up with a solution I
would no no I'm talking about the
amendment just for the study committee
just for just to keep section two yeah
correct and we made section one keep
section two yeah we've got 100 bills to
get through oh I don't I totally
understand that if you can do the
legwork with with legislative services
oh okay oh that I absolutely can do that
do you want a little bit of time to
Let's uh we want to do and maybe you
want to have more discussion then
there's got to be a lot more discussion
yeah
um and I'd like to have director Quinlan
um offer some you know there'll be
questions there yes I have questions
um I can we just went through something
like this not where Charter Schools but
in the village District I live in our
fire station and property was donated
to the Village District water district
Haverhill corner
then the town wants to take it over the
town couldn't take it over because it
was written in the covenants from the
person who donated all this that nothing
could occur
uh going elsewhere if you choose to no
longer own this Village District of
Haverhill corner it will revert back to
the original owner
and so there's a there's a number of
questions here in which we need to
answer uh yeah and and uh we're getting
into the the not just the outfits that
you've mentioned near these departments
but justice as well yeah so um yeah
there's a lot of work that has to be
done on this so I I will help you in any
way that I can I certainly don't know
the answer to how you pull this all
together and because you can as you
understand it's complicated and there
are a lot of different covenants out
there probably I'm not familiar with it
but we have different types of charter
schools as well right I only love
versions and I looked at just 10 of them
I mean I didn't look at all 30 or
however many there are thank you very
much are there further questions
representative Tanner
thank you um
regular Public Schools district
Community public schools are non-profit
really aren't they
uh
my understanding you know and like maybe
a lawyer could would tell you something
different is that for
um Public Schools they they are they are
a government entity and some of them is
probably common for them to have a
separate
organization that
um accepts
donations
or I think towns can accept donations
but then you have overseer of the trust
funds that kind of thing
so that structure they're they're not
they are not 501 3cs a public school is
not a 501 3C but they can have 501 3C uh
uh Public School can have a 501c3 uh for
charitable donations or yes and the
money is completely separate it's not
part of the school budget or and it and
it doesn't maybe you can ask it like
superintendent and it doesn't have
taxpayer resourced money in it they're
not co-mingled for sure okay and I don't
know if we've got the answer there
is a lot of different angles and twists
and all this so I think before we come
to conclusion that quickly it's not a
one pager
uh further questions
thank you very much
Mr Quinlan are you available
director of quinlas the director of the
charitable trusts here in New Hampshire
welcome uh thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Diane Quinlan and I serve as the
Director of charitable trust and with me
here today is Michael Haley he serves as
the assistant director of charitable
trust uh thank you for taking my
testimony as you can see I have
distributed some written testimony but
I'm also here to provide some oral
testimony and um answer your questions
we're not taking a position on House
Bill 550 we're just here to offer you
some background information
um first of all by way of background our
one of the very important
responsibilities of our office and the
charitable trust unit of the Attorney
General's office is to protect the
Public's interest in the use of assets
devoted to charitable purposes and to
protect the charitable intent of donors
the health of the non-profit sector
really relies in part on the principle
that when a donor offers a gift to a
charity for a particular purpose that
particular purpose and that intent is
enforceable
so charter schools are organized in New
Hampshire as private non-profit
charitable corporations that are exempt
from federal income tax under Section
501c3 of the Internal Revenue code
in order to qualify for tax-exempt
status under Section 501c3 of the
Internal Revenue code when a corporation
files its articles of agreement must
include a dissolution Clause that
indicates that upon dissolution the
assets shall be distributed either to
another
501c3 eligible Corporation or
organization or a government agency
charter schools in New Hampshire are
governed by their own Boards of trustees
and they're subject to the oversight of
our office they're required to submit a
registration application and thereafter
file annual reports with our office
in the event that they dissolve and some
of those charitable charter schools have
dissolved in the last year
the charter school must submit a final
annual report with our office that
indicates where those charitable assets
have been distributed and one of the
roles of our office is to ensure that
the assets were distributed in
accordance with the terms of the
Articles of agreement
and um consistent with donor intent with
respect to any donor restricted funds so
it's important to remember that Charter
School assets May consist not only of
assets they receive from the state but
also assets they may receive from
private sources
some of those gifts may be subject to
one or more specific restrictions on
their use and the school has an
obligation to comply with the terms of
those restrictions for example if a
School receives a donation that's to be
used exclusively to build a playing
field or a building that property must
be used for those purposes
so in general when a New Hampshire
charitable Corporation dissolves it's
unrestricted charitable assets are
distributed in accordance with those
articles of agreement I mentioned
but certain donor restricted funds held
by charitable Corporation can't simply
be distributed in accordance with that
dissolution provision
for example if an individual donates a
building to a charter school for the
sole purpose of operating a school for
students in grades 7 through 12.
upon dissolution the state can't simply
sell the bill the schools simply can't
sell the building and give the assets to
the state or distribute the building to
another 501c3 that's because the school
accepted the restricted when he they
accepted that restricted gift they have
an obligation to comply with the terms
of that restriction that is enforceable
by our office uh in the charitable trust
unit
in most cases in order to change the
purpose or the administration of a
restricted gift like that it requires a
trip to court
a petition for site pray it's called or
a petition for deviation in general
terms
that's typically the way that a
restricted gift would be distributed so
it could not be returned to the state
because the state that it's not
consistent with the terms of of the the
gift
the legislature doesn't have the
authority to change the purpose or
administration of a restricted gift
so we note that the um discussion today
is really taught not talking about
existing Charter Schools but that's a
really important distinction because the
United States Supreme Court has held
that the government can't change the
charter of an existing charitable
Corporation in order to assume control
over it that case which is cited in the
written testimony that I distributed was
a case called Dartmouth College versus
Woodward and Daniel Webster actually
argued on the part of Dartmouth College
in that case the New Hampshire
legislature attempted to change the
charter and convert Dartmouth College
which was founded by a congregational
Minister and governed by its own Board
of Trustees
to a secular institution called
Dartmouth University
but the United States Supreme Court held
that Dartmouth College was not a civil
institution that could be employed in
the administration of government it was
a private charitable Institution
the court therefore found that the state
could not it had no authority to change
the charter of that private charitable
institution or change the purpose of any
of its charitable funds
so as I mentioned we're not taking a
position on this particular bill but
we're happy to answer any questions
thank you very much further questions
representative Tanner
thank you I am so confused but
um
so in the case of our Charter Schools
the New Hampshire charter schools which
are essentially private non-profit
charitable organizations
is the when they receive money from our
educational trust fund is that
considered a donation
from the state
is not this the same thing as a private
donation for a particular purpose so is
that
does the state give
does the state on a regular basis
besides Charters give
donations to charitable organizations
the state does offer grants to
non-profit charitable corporations
frequently and some of those grants are
subject to certain restrictions as well
but the
the
but the money that we give per pupil
which is based on
on our educational trust fund
um is not a grant
is it a donation
that's a fair question and it's it's a
very charter schools are very unusual
animals there aren't a lot of Charters
uh comparable situations which is why we
raise some of these concerns when um we
were asked about this particular bill we
wanted to make it clear that they're
because it's a 501c3 it has certain
obligations under the the law and
subject to our jurisdiction but it may
also have other restrictions under the
um uh their state grants or state
Charter as well I have one more just one
one question
um is this usual in other states I mean
do you know if um
because the there's charter schools in
every state is this a common setup for
Charter Schools I do not know the answer
I'm sorry I can try to check on that but
I don't know yet okay thank you sorry
further questions representative uh Luna
and Woodcock and then Milo thank you
very much Mr chair and thank you very
much uh uh for uh for uh joining us this
morning with respect to a comment that
you made in the in the Dartmouth case I
think you you suggested that that the
court
um
said that the government could not
you know require a disposition of assets
uh as part of taking over uh uh uh you
know the the that organization and uh
but but I was wondering
um could
um could the the could the state of New
Hampshire uh
apply some you know Provisions that
would either have to be included in um
in new
um School Charters as well as would be
read into existing School Chargers uh
Charters with respect to if it's if it's
not clear in the charter how you know
what the dispositions would be how um
State dollars
um would be um would be taken care of in
a dissolution how private dollars
obviously the your your the charitable
trust division certainly if even if it's
not in the in the school Charter is
going to be read against a certain law
um it is respect to charitable donations
but but does the does the state have
some room to work with within the
Supreme Court decision and uh and uh
putting in place some policy to be
either included in Charters or read in
conjunction with existing Charters at
question the Dartmouth case dealt with
an existing charity so if you're talking
about uh the uh establishing a rule that
for uh future in order to be approved as
a charter school in the future then your
dissolution provision must indicate that
the asset shall be distributed to the
local government or the state
for the future if that's the condition
then I think that then the charter would
then be accepted on those terms then I
think that's okay for the future that
would not uh change the fact that any
privately donated funds with restricted
purposes would still follow the intent
of the donor and still have to go to
court
okay with existing Charities though I
think that the court has made it pretty
clear that you the government can't
change the charter of an existing
charitable organization
um thank you thank you very much Mr
chair thanks for the clarification there
um one of the reasons this is so
important the chair would would probably
knows where I'm going with this is that
we've got several bills also that would
open up Charter Schools to be recipients
to State build School building Aid and
um and so if one of those TR if if such
an existing Charter School were to
receive state aid for construction of a
of a school building and then let's say
a handful of years later was um became
insolvent and uh and dissolved
How would how would those
once State assets
um the uh be handled
that's jumping a little bit
but but would it be would it
I mean how would how would the
charitable trust division handle handle
that
so yeah
hard to speculate what that looks like
but I think that if um a gift is given
with a certain restrictions and
conditions and those conditions are met
that's then that can go back to this to
the state if that's what the condition
is the building shall be used for the
charter school for as long as it remains
approved charter school after which it
returns to the to the state
thing something like that
further question represent whitcock good
morning good morning thank you both for
for being here
um two two questions uh the first one is
does doe uh confer with you oh it is
China school application to go through
you
um prior to be certified as approved by
Doe for initial so thank you for your
question no the the Department of
Education doesn't consult with us it's
not part of the process but it's my
understanding that they do take a look
at and um to determine whether or not
they are registered with our office so
it's not an official requirement but I
believe that they do look to see whether
or not they're registered and in good
standing with our office yeah and I
think it's a state board state board
okay everyone will have to depart
representative here I have one yes thank
you the second one during your uh verbal
testimony the oral testimony she said um
you mentioned that the child school is
providing annual reporter view to you
can you just give us a quick glimpse of
what that might be in the report yes uh
under uh
the non-profit corporations that are New
Hampshire based must submit annual
reports to our office including
chartered schools that annual report
sets forth certain information that we
review such as the current number the
names of the board members
their financial situa information for
example if they file a 990 and they all
do they need to submit their 990 with
our office they also need to submit
their audited Financial reports because
the vast majority of them have Revenue
in excess of 2 million a year in
addition they provide certain
information about their governance
whether or not there's been any
conflicts of interest things like that
and then in the event that they dissolve
they also have to file an additional
attachment that sets forth where the
assets have been distributed oftentimes
and we prefer it before a charter school
or other non-profit dissolves they'll
contact our office and say this is what
our plan is and we say well do you have
any restricted assets and we talk about
where where those go okay thank you
thank you master you're welcome
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for being here
um my question really relates to the
asset allocation
as we've talked about earlier this
morning
Charter Schools receive state funding on
a per-pupil basis they receive donations
as we've heard testimony in Prior and
prior hearings here uh they're raising
anywhere from eight to ten percent of
their budget through fundraising
activities I want to focus on those two
elements there I'm not dealing with a uh
a donor who says I'm going to build a
field for the school that's not what I'm
dealing with primarily operational costs
here
and they co-mingle those uh to
administer the program that's that's
there one day ultimately uh decide to
dissolve how do those various assets
then begin to uh get distributed to
wherever because you've got the
donations which are just generic
donations to help the administration not
specifically targeted and you've got the
state aid money that's coming in they
co-mingle to create a budget of three
million dollars let's say
how does how does one determine how that
gets allocated from the state vis-a-vis
that of private uh fundraising
activities
thank you for your question generally
they don't get allocated separately
those are considered to be unrestricted
funds and so those unrestricted funds
are distributed in accordance with the
terms of the Articles of agreement
that's generally the way it works it's
only where there are restricted funds so
if they're fundraising for a particular
purpose that is to build a field that
might be a separate fund that's separate
that's a restricted fund for a
particular purpose that's where we come
in we protect the donor intent but with
respect to the other funds those are
considered to be unrestricted funds and
they follow the articles of agreement
yes is that then where the when does the
court come into the determination of the
of the uh allocation the court comes in
with re with respect to restricted funds
for a particular purpose okay thank you
very much
good afternoon
thank you Mr chair thank you for helping
us understand this or attempt to I have
two questions
you may have answered the first one but
it's not clear to me
are the current Charter Schools articles
of agreement in compliance with the
issues and concerns that are being used
this bill is proposed
the I haven't studied all of the
Articles of agreement for all Charter
Schools but generally they provide that
the assets shall be distributed to
another 501c3 or a government entity
that's what they have to say in order to
comply with
um
to to in order to be eligible for status
as a 501c3
organization some may specify which
government agency the money goes to or
which 501c3 entity it goes to but some
are just more General so I can't tell
you exactly what all of them say okay
yeah yes
so
it sounds like it was within the law
that
a closing charter school could give
their assets to a 501c3 that has nothing
to do with education
under the Articles of agreement that's
the way that they could
um distribute the fund
generally we try to step in in those
kinds of cases and
try to get them to distribute their
funds to an organization that's similar
to the purpose for which they were
established it's my understanding too
and I I
admit that I am not as familiar with
Charter Schools as maybe someone who
works for the Department of Education
but it's my understanding that there may
be something in one of the regulations
that requires that assets be distributed
to the local school district
which would be consistent with
the articles of agreement
so I have one unrelated different
question entirely can you please quickly
do it so on the question of Financial
instability preceding Financial
insolvency
does the trust division get involved to
help a school that's not thriving
financially but isn't yet closing the
doors
thank you for your question oftentimes
when we receive an annual report or if
we receive a call for example from the
Department of Education they may say uh
Gene you should be aware that this
school is not doing well financially in
that case what we'll do is we'll meet
with the board of directors and we'll
talk to the board about what their plans
are what are you going to try to do to
resolve this issue or are you going to
close and which and sometimes that's the
best case scenario is the the best thing
is is for them ultimately to close so
that they can distribute those assets to
another school that could use it to
benefit those same students so we do get
involved whenever we hear about
charter schools that are in trouble and
we follow them closely
we've had a number of colleges in that
Realm yes that's true yes uh further
discussion thank you very much thank you
I don't have any other pink cards on
that bill so we're going to conclude the
hearing on 5 50. we're going to take a
five minute stand up for everybody here
and then we'll come right back and start
up uh the next uh bill which would be uh
382.
thank you
that is something awesome
[Laughter]
it is
yeah yeah
I'm sort of
impossible
um
technology
experience
go ahead with the next bill here it's uh
HP 382
this is an act authorizing local school
boards to give students release time for
participation in religious instruction
and an elective course for the purpose
purposes of satisfying curriculum
requirements we don't have the prime
sponsor here so I'm going to have a
member from the committee to sit down
out there please and introduce the bill
read the title and say thank you very
much and then we can get into the
discussion if they're folks that came to
do that today so
um
representative Woodcock would you like
to introduce it or represent Belcher
would you like to introduce it sure
thank you
good morning chairman Ladd good morning
members
record my name is representative Mike
Belcher at Carroll District Four
I am introducing today
House Bill 382 enact authorizing local
school boards to give students release
time for participation in religious
instruction in an elective course for
the purpose of satisfying curriculum
requirements
have we heard this one yeah we heard
what was the day
well I guess you don't have to do it I
believe there's a different rep on this
I believe the other one was rep garage
let's see the two that were very similar
382.
hold on
foreign
this vote if I recall correctly I
believe there was an email from the uh
sponsor of this bill asking the
committee to itl the bill because there
was a duplicate yeah yeah but there is a
slight difference
yeah
we've done all of them though right
yeah yeah I think we've got it covered
thank you very much
thank you
everybody
okay
this happened though that happens when
you get so many bills coming in and our
administrative support is you know John
down there juggling as well
with many committees so uh something
like this is bound to happen
uh the next bill was is at 10 o'clock
actually I'm I'm looking the wrong day
now we're good
what is your uh what are we gonna do
with this three and three at this point
uh we're not going to exec anything
today
we will well
okay
I misread the calendar because I thought
we had some other ones here we've
already had I thought we would be that
enough
foreign
those people are not here we would not
be exacting any bills today
and so that's the way we're going to
funnel through we do it once we're going
to be known to do it again and that's
you know inappropriate you know
procedure here
so what we're going to do we
so at we had a bill schedule for 634
this puts us back on schedule almost so
it's 10 40 that we're supposed to be
going into 634 relative to the students
participation in religious instruction
to a satisfy elective curriculum
requirements see these are both very
similar
so we'll turn to 634
your research out of the same data
secure
this this bill has not been
uh so
is the sponsor of 634 yes that's correct
it was at the end of the day
here
so could you introduce this one please
from the represent Belcher
you got it there
good yeah
good morning again chairman Ladd
honorable members
for the record representative Mike
Belcher Carroll District Four here to
introduce House Bill 634 Dash FN enact
relative to students participation in
religious instruction to satisfy
elective requirements
thank you very much thank you very much
you probably need to fill out a pink
card
okay are there any other pink cards
yeah fill it out and and after you yeah
thank you Mr chair honorable members of
the education committee uh for the
record my name is representative Matt
Simon I represent Grafton district one
Littleton Lisbon Lyman Sugar Hill bath
and Monroe I apologize for my attire
today I was not anticipating on being on
the state house I was doing work for my
other job I just happened to be here uh
in fact I was sitting down in the
cafeteria doing some work and noticed
this hearing and thought I would come up
to listen in but as nobody's here to
testify on it I figured I would step in
because I'm somewhat knowledgeable on
the topic I just wanted to make sure a
few points were made
um the bill itself uh seeks to allow
students to leave the premises of a
public education facility for the
purposes of religious instruction and
then receive credit for that instruction
as an elective
leaving school premises for the purposes
of a religious instruction is already
constitutional according to Zurich
versus colossian Supreme Court decision
although those courses cannot be had on
school premises they can be had off
school premises so long as the cost for
transportation other costs associated
with it are not incurred by the taxpayer
they are incurred by whoever is offering
the course
this bill the only difference between
that and this bill from what I can see
is that it would then satisfy an
elective
credit for the school
the Supreme Court is also ruled that
um
that the state cannot uh show favoritism
of one religion over another including
secularism so I would argue that if an
elective is available as long as that
elective does not somehow otherwise
infringe upon the Constitution the free
exercise clause and salvation Clause
wouldn't pertain here and the school
should be able to take those electives
as credit
so that's it in brief and I'm happy to
take any questions that I might be able
to answer for you if you have any any
questions for representative Simon
representative Tanner and then represent
Belcher thank you you probably don't
have a copy of the bill but down in her
first page line 27
there's it says enacting T capital T
capital r capital e capital c capital A
and I have no idea what that stands for
would you mind if I just want to grab a
copy oh thank you so much uh I'm sorry
representative where was it
representative I'm 27 on the first page
all in cap letters
that's the first page
line 27
Mr chair if I could answer that it's
line one of the bill it's an acronym for
totally Educational Credit actually it
took me a while to find that thank you
well thank you thank you for the
question thank you for the answer
representative appreciate that
representative is helpful
you're up thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking the question
um is it would be correct and I think
we've heard testimony on this before but
would it be correct that this doesn't
actually place any burden on the school
or financial burden on the taxpayers
that is correct yeah if I mean there
would be question uh constitutionally as
far as Supreme Court rulings as to
whether it would be constitutional if it
did
um although with the recent Kennedy
versus Remington decision and the
overtressman of London versus kutzman
that might be questionable uh that might
fall differently
um but certainly as long as it doesn't
incur uh over into the taxpayer it's
constitutional according to Supreme
Court decisions thank you
corruption Damon
please look at lines 23 through 30
articles
um seven and eight
and comment or explain on the Merit or
lack thereof of the language there
was a I'm sorry representative was that
on page on the first page of the bill
lines 23 through 30 the last two Roman
numeral points
besides with one of the largest cultural
medicines in America I apologize I'll
have to read it just briefly and then
thank you for the question
representative um I'm not 100 sure on
lines 23-25 and I think I can speak to
26 through 30 because they come up in
constitutional decisions at the Supreme
Court level
um
up until the 20th century education was
primarily done by religious institutions
it wasn't until the early 20th century
that it became compulsory for all
students of a certain age to attend
public schools
um
with it being compulsory and the nature
of the academics that are offered within
a school system just just by necessity
by definition
those courses do take in turn some form
of religious instruction the Supreme
Court has pretty much recognized this
whether it's secularism if you define
secularism as
um as a religious kind of belief system
let me give you an example because I'm
sure that sounds very confusing
if for example I was to bring a
Christian sexual education program into
a school system and basically teach that
sex should happen between a man and a
woman only within the confines of
marriage that would be deemed
unconstitutional on the merits that
it that's a religious belief on sexual
behavior between two people
um however the Supreme Court has also
said that the state can't undermine
religion in its teaching well if there's
any sexual education teaching in in a
state school at all you're going to end
up either promoting something or
undermining something so if a Christian
Student goes into a classroom in which
um something contrary to that it's fine
to have sex with whomever whenever
whether you're married or not
um that teaching undermines a religious
belief as well and therefore is
inherently religious So within a
compulsory system it's nearly impossible
to keep a world viewer and ideology out
and I believe that's what that section
is referring to that we have to make it
equal for everybody and not just for one
particular belief system
and once again to know to know cost of
the taxpayer
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair uh thank you again just to clarify
when you're referring to uh the
religious nature of secularism well I
think you might have been referring to
the Supreme Court finding that secular
humanism is a religion is that what
you're referring to uh yeah thank you
for the question representative and yes
that is what I'm referring to
um I can't remember the case off the top
of my head I apologize there's about a
dozen of them
um but in the case uh
the people arguing uh for Religious
Freedom I guess um I can't remember all
the details as far as that's concerned
but the people arguing for Religious
Freedom said well if you remove all
other religion out of the school system
then you're basically making secularism
a religion and you can't make secular
secularism secularism a religion to the
exclusion of other religions the Supreme
Court's response to that was at that
time
um no we couldn't do that
um but we're not doing that and then
later on there came into question
whether or not that's what they were
actually doing
um and so especially with the more
recent Supreme Court decisions uh the
question of how The Establishment Clause
versus the free exercise clause is
really really kind of changing and come
back under a question
um so yes under Supreme Court law it is
very
it's arguable at the very least and
probable I think that secularism would
be looked at as a religion under those
definitions
for the questions representative
Woodcock thank you this is the
clarification for you a question or it
could be for the representative uh
because I'm confused on line 17 on page
two
uh whereas talking that the course
credit is talking about earning credit
time may earn credit course credit for
participation
uh so my question is
so a student goes to a religious school
for instruction off of public school
premises during school time
and they earn credit just for going
just participation is uh I guess my
first it's my first question they don't
have to do anything to have to go
because I'm a representative
um thank you for the question if you
look online 20 it says the State Board
of Education shall also adopt minimum
standards for class attendance necessary
to qualify for the credit right but
that's just the tenants okay yeah yeah
just for showing at that point they just
have to go yeah okay so I'm trying to
find out uh representative Ladd uh if
this earned credit goes toward the
graduation credit when all the person
has to do is just show up
there's a there's a huge process to the
courses which are offered according to
education 306 where the mental standards
for public school approval of which a
high school must offer I think at a
minimum 43 different courses that's what
they have in their catalog to speak of
course is offered you're required to
have a minimum of 20 credits to graduate
some school districts have more than
that
the process for approval as we've had
several bills come forward saying well I
took this course in school a on
transferring School B who approves that
the building principal does right but
you do it in conjunction with the or you
disapproved based upon if there's a
similar course which is similar to and
has those basic competencies built in
within which are also in ed306 the word
competencies so the process is such that
the State Board May set certain
standards but the the the
approval of courses that are offered
through this local school are done by
the local school board and the
administration within that board
so I don't know if I answered your
question but that's briefly how I
believe it happens and I really want to
understand the 23 I understand the 16
core requirements and those people I
understand I'm just trying to find out
how a Class
A United States board can set up the
attendance requirements but how of
course that only requires sitting there
only requires sitting there uh it has no
other no other way to to
um uh verify competencies is uh required
to be part of a graduation requirement
except there's a graduate requirement
does the bill has area SAS be modified
in order to really satisfy for example
you're talking about the State Board
shall also adopt minimal standards for
attendance
is that going to be done through
rulemaking if so rule making is not even
identified in the Bill thank you okay
thank you yeah represent Belcher thank
you Mr chair and just to piggyback off
of Representative woodcock's question
would you see legal or constitutional
issues arising from the state possibly
trying to develop competencies or
guidelines around a religious education
foreign
this is um
thank you for the question
representative
um if you if you really want to
understand this issue you do have to do
a lot of reading on it
um one of the main contentions that came
up when the when the state decided to
Institute compulsory education
um in which everybody had to pay
taxpayer dollars into it and then
um send their kids or pay subsequently
extra money to be outside was that they
basically took over a religious role in
the society at the time and so the
Supreme Court in the 1948 case basically
stated
that
um
Church education whether it's parochial
through the Catholic church or you know
about this school or whatever was really
an extension of that church
um because it performed certain Church
related functions
um where the state could not step in and
create its own church according to the
con you know the Federal Constitution uh
in competition to other churches and
then require taxpayer funds to go into
it
um and then Force everybody to go to
their church or pay extra to go to their
own church they did by extension create
this kind of tension and conflict when
they did the with the school system
because they did go into direct
competition with educational schools and
so there's always been this tension
between the two as to what institutes
the role of the state and what
institutes the role of the religion how
the free exercise clause your ability to
practice your own religion when in a
school building comes into play with a
teacher's role is what they have the
freedom to do in their classroom when
religion comes into play because when
you say that the state is basically
um
the state is overseeing the
establishment of religion through the
school system or trying to keep that
from happening in that way in total
competition with the church itself
um those lines get those lines get
really really blurry really really fast
and so
um I think that with zoroth and Claus
and what they said essentially was there
has to be a place for Religious
Education to exist during the school day
it can happen off of site and
um
so long as it's not on the tax Paradigm
um but yeah I don't know that the school
that the state would have any say in
particular on what the religion could or
could not teach during that time I think
that would go against the Constitution
and so
um it's it's the difficulty in
marriaging these two things together
um and one of the reasons why we've had
so much trouble with it in the past
thank you for the questions
for not thinking what you're going to do
today Pat you certainly got you know
like thank you so much for your time I
apologize for extending your day a
little bit more but I think it's it is
an important concept and I hope that the
committee gives it some serious
consideration thank you very much thank
you
do we have any other cards on this bill
is there anybody in the public here that
wanted to speak to this bill
if not
we're closing it down
and we're going to go on the 552
relative making incentive grants for
school districts that improve in certain
assessment scores
so 552
representative Moffett you are here
welcome to education thank you Mr chair
happy to be here uh very impressed by
representative Simon just coming out of
nowhere and doing what he did uh he's
welcome to stay around and introduce
this bill perhaps or we're not
uh for the record uh again I'm
representative Mike Moffett of Merrimack
District for the beautiful towns of
Canterbury and Loudoun
so uh to get right through this I
believe in public education served us
well over the many years I went to
Public Schools my kids had a great
Public School experience or experiences
here in Concord
I served in a public school board I
taught in public post-secondary
institutions I served two terms in this
committee so public education is a big
part of my journey and I care about it
and I see it being in trouble
the test scores are down public support
is down enrollment is down partly due to
demographics but for other reasons as
well
uh homeschooling members have
skyrocketed charter schools are
proliferated uh the response to the the
new EFA option has been overwhelming so
why are all these things happening and
I'm sure there are a number of reasons
for all this
Bruno
uh we'll we'll come back we'll be happy
to come back to that
um but uh my feeling
is that we need to have some do some new
thinking we hear a lot about Innovation
and education and to some folks that
means like taking the walls down in
schools and that type of innovation but
honestly again having been in this
education culture
in some areas Innovation just is really
hard to to manifest itself
in public education where public
spending is now approaching twenty
thousand dollars per student per year
twenty thousand dollars per student per
year
it is a perception fair or not that
schools don't celebrate or promote
achievement as as they might uh some
schools have eliminated valedictorians
some schools have done Away With Honors
tracks so there's that perception that
many schools teach to the lowest common
denominator we've all heard that how
true is it I'm not sure every district
is different
uh there's a perception that the lowest
common denominator is tied in with with
equity and there's a fear that sometimes
proselytizing takes place that schools
focus on less the school focus is
shifted away from academics and into
other areas uh diversity Equity
inclusion climate change on and on so
we've heard parents tell us in some
cases in this Committee in tears
that their kids are not being challenged
in school so many of us want to look at
this address this help this uh
and we've I think we've made some some
nice steps I think the Unified sports
measure the gifted student measure the
Civics bill that are all law uh are good
steps that parents applaud
so I know this committee gets about 100
bills a year uh but again how many of
those bills deal with teaching or
learning or pedagogy and by education I
mean learning
I mean achievement
I mean academic excellence
things that parents really care about
um and this is a bill that's about
learning and achievement HP 552
establishes a fund whereby the doe can
create a mechanism to reward schools
that demonstrate measurable Improvement
in math achievement
um representative Hobson and I chatted
with some Folks At Doe about this
incentive Grant concept a couple years
ago and it was talked about formulas and
in which assessments to use and how to
implement et cetera et cetera
who eventually realized that statute
is not necessarily the place to put in
overly prescriptive definitions as to
how to move this measure forward we saw
our job is simply to raise awareness
about this approach to celebrate
Improvement and encourage Improvement to
shine a light on the concept of
rewarding achievement to find funding
and to task doe with working out the
details in cooperation with relevant
stakeholders so once a formula is
established and published then then
schools would not compete against each
other in this bill
came up a year last term so I'm
repeating all this stuff that some of
you have already heard
it's not about competing against other
schools it's simply about trying to
improve their own results based on their
own baselines
so there's only rewards here there's no
punishment of course you know there'll
be some statistical issues it has come
up before what if a school is already
performing relatively High
then the the room for improvement
according to the formula will be
different from a school that's
performing relatively poorly which I
totally understand that of course but
that's the intent of this initiative the
schools that are really doing really
poorly will more easily qualify for a
reward
so again we shouldn't let the perfect be
the enemy of the good
and I'm sure all kinds of questions will
again come up which is fine that's why
we're here and I see representative
Simon is left unfortunately
hoping he might stick around
so uh we in the past we've had a formula
where we give schools school districts
money if they're third grade reading
scores are down
so how well do we monitor the results of
the many millions of dollars that we've
sent to schools with low third grade
reading scores
uh is there much in the way of
accountability
folks who want
charter schools to be accountable
for their spending fairly asked about
accountability and transparency
shouldn't that also apply to the third
grade reading scores and all the money
that is directed that way is there data
on how this extra money is used
because the extra spending made a
difference with the third graders
because the extra money in fact gone
to reading programs as one would assume
it would that was the reason that
they're giving money to schools with a
low third grade scores
some see that as a progress incentive
and I get that
schools do poorly give them money
we want to think that we could also have
room for a small program where schools
do well
and they get rewarded so back days b552
so if incentivizing achievement
Improvement results in a school winning
a 50 000 reward or award what will that
mean number one it means a nice chunk of
money for the district to spend as it
wishes number two it means that the
school winning award will have reason to
celebrate the whole school community
self-esteem morale Pride could only
improve number three parents would be
thrilled
if the school that their child or
children went to uh won an award because
of improvements in this area parents
would love that number four lessons can
be learned and shared when when when
when
so folks might ask how how did if a
school if this gets into play a place in
a school improves their scores and some
folks will say so what happened how did
you improve your scores
well that's kind of the a cool thing
about this if it moves forward maybe the
school created a math team
like the school I once taught at had
that went to math meets maybe they
created some sort of innovative peer
tutoring
initiative maybe they created a math
club that might involve alumni parents
Engineers technicians accountants people
use math
who can speak to the relevance and you
value and utility of Matt again I and
for many students say what do I need to
know this algebra stuff I mean I'm never
going to need that well
I think it's important to help students
understand the utility and the value of
math on and on all kinds of
possibilities and whatever truly
effective approaches that award-winning
schools develop can be shared and
emulated
and finally this goes into his last year
was senatorium study it was part of the
subcommittee they met several times and
we spent a lot of time on this one of
the changes that we made reflected some
input we get to specifically focus on
math
in the subcommittee voted to recommend
OTP and then in October the soil
committee or the education Committee in
October uh endorsed the OTP
recommendation from the subcommittee
so I hope that the time that people
spend in in subcommittees and then with
subsequent full committee endorsements I
hope that means something otherwise you
know why would anyone want to work on
the subcommittee if all that work is not
is from not
so uh
we I think we need that new paradigm
people are watching and others will
watch later and they're hoping that we
can do some stuff that can really make a
difference and I'd be happy to take
questions if there are any thank you
very much representative Moffett are
there questions representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Moffett uh it's
definitely recognizing good work is so
very important and I'm sure there are
more successes than we even give credit
for right so my question is how could
this bill be Equitable in Awards with
districts who can afford full Staffing
in a math department versus those
districts who can't afford the full
Staffing sure thank you for the question
and I kind of touched on that a little
bit because I acknowledge that
difference law schools are different
some are in different places some have
more resources and I think that it's my
earlier comment in that area a school
that lacks resources that uh has more
room to improve they really have an
advantage I think over schools that are
already performing well they have the
resources and so getting back to
Innovation schools that maybe lack those
resources this is an opportunity if this
gets into place to pull in as I said
parents uh statisticians and years
whatever and and pull them in to be part
of the process of raising awareness and
and focusing attention on that so I'm
saying your point and and hopefully I
explained it enough a couple times to
acknowledge that schools are different
and that that shouldn't stop us from
trying to give doe a chance to put a
formula into place
thank you for other questions from the
committee
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
good morning good morning everybody
didn't take your advice
that being said Mike I'm looking at wine
8789 on the page one of the bill uh and
it talks about the student performance
Improvement if I recall build some of
this last session uh it dealt with
providing those with me on my page
the main page
uh it's under number two the that that
area last time it took talked about
taking schools are doing well
and giving him a reward for doing well
basically helping those that are good to
be better I didn't make any uh
acknowledgment of those before are
getting better
um but I'm trying to determine if this
is the exact same language because I'm
reading it differently in my mind uh
when I look at lines eight and nine that
says it talks about uh test scores which
documents Improvement so the intent of
this bill equal for school districts are
doing very very poorly and show
Improvement equally eligible for this
fund or it's just school districts are
already doing well and it's a reward for
doing well sure thank you for the
question it's it's one that we try to
speak to before uh and it's a good
question and it brings us back to the
formula that uh
is not part of this legislation uh
formula TBD to be determined by the
Department of Education with input from
stakeholders
um
every school if this moves forward uh I
anticipate the formula would establish
establish a criteria in other words a
baseline will take a year of math scores
in whatever year
and then that's the Baseline so if they
improve by uh five percent ten percent
um whatever the formula arrives at then
every school competes only against
itself so uh whenever the Baseline score
Baseline accumulative score is four math
scores then if they again as you just
said is improved by certain percentage
they'll get the the reward the the
tricky part about that is uh the good
questions like that's a good question
about the formula
and so
in terms of arriving at the formula
that's something that we need as I said
Department of Education to have the
latitude to develop
um is it when we first started working
in this we we we're dealing with that
type of question we're trying to come up
with formulas and prescriptive language
we finally figured out that the way to
move this forward is to find some
funding for it uh get it in the statute
and then instead of getting down in the
weeds and putting the statute the
formula trust doe to uh uh come up with
a formula that that works if that
addresses your question somewhat
um
somewhat thank you thank you Mr chairman
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this bill forward I'd like to
clarify a little bit based on uh rep
Wilcox question
um obviously the formula will be left
for the Department of Education but it's
pretty clear right here in language
um that the metric being measured is not
to be how good a school is doing but
Improvement correct
so that said the schools doing the not
best the the worst you could say who
have the most room to improve
are the most likely to receive Grant
because they have the most room to
improve would that be correct yes I
think I tried to State something that
effect earlier yes yes thank you
I have a question for you representative
um the the grants which the school
district receives are and I liken it a
little bit to what we received the state
650 million dollars NASA money and Etc
all the stabilization grants we received
there are some uses within that that the
district had to comply with in order to
use the money
how are you going to or is it your
thought that a district not received
this grant money then use it to fix our
roof or should it be used for
instruction
sure and again uh after
in a few minutes this bill will belong
to this committee and obviously the
committee can can amend it or not as it
wishes my personal vision is that the
reward go to the district and they can
do whatever they want with it it's a
local control issue and the thing is if
they get 50 you know there could be
twenty fifty thousand dollar Awards if
if this million dollars uh moves forward
and my feeling is that uh they could the
schools could use it for anything they
want locally now if the committee wanted
to uh get in the weeds a little bit and
require that the award or the reward be
uh dedicated to
something academic or math I mean that
would be up to you but again my vision
is just reward the schools and let the
districts uh do what they want with the
award
they can't put a monument up front to
represent a Moffat I think they could
that that that is a local control
decision
representing cordial
like you're taking my question I'm just
curious as to the reasoning
um as to why this is limited to
mathematics and doesn't include like
reading and language arts Improvement
that's a good question and the answer is
that uh as part of the interim study
process we get some input from some uh
esteemed people who suggested that we
narrow the focus to math so that's so
that came about but uh if the committee
so the bill is math specific if the
committee wanted to broaden that again
that would be up to the to the committee
thank you
further questions
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
yep and I do want to just say that when
representative
from the North Conway area said he was
glad he didn't take my advice that was
not an academic issue that had to do
with the uh the Super Bowl and and uh
Philadelphia not winning I think
have a good one
okay uh Brian Hawkins from the Nea New
Hampshire
uh thank you Mr chairman for the record
Brian Hawkins representing Nea New
Hampshire today uh the uh State's
education dollars that it has available
to them are are very precious and as we
know they are not uh unlimited as this
committee well knows as you're looking
to uh see how to improve the state
funding formula for uh for an adequate
education if the state has uh by the way
I'm here today in opposition to the bill
I forgot to state that at the front
um the state has a million dollars to
spend uh with regard to improving
um performance on mathematics I think it
would be better spent first to make sure
that there are enough available Math
teachers and paraprofessionals in our
schools
um before we uh appropriate it for this
type of a program
um there are as we know there's a
shortage of paraprofessionals and other
staff that we've discussed in this
committee before
um and helping school districts making
making sure that there are qualified
individuals who are able to help our
students
um the legislature ought to prioritize
that first making sure that they have
the necessary equipment to learn
the math science stem skills
as well
uh broadening an ELO program that they
might have or want to start
I think that would be maybe a more
appropriate usage of the million dollars
that this bill is suggesting uh to to
appropriate so uh
I'll close my testimony there and happy
to take any questions
thank you very much I got a question for
you is it wise for a school district to
use one-time Grant Monies
for activities which may involve labor
or ongoing expenses
uh I will I will tell you anytime
um that type of expenditure is requested
it is often met with hesitancy because
of that um very reason that one time uh
the one-time funds and so
um so
I would say no so in follow-up if you
were a building School Board member or
School District Board member or a a
principal that received this grant could
you find ways to use money such as this
to towards instruction or curriculum on
a one-time basis in your school
I think it I think it would be difficult
I think there are a lot of schools have
been doing I think uh with some of the
one-time funds that they've been
receiving uh have been attempting to use
those funds in ways that don't uh
encumber uh long-term
um unsustainable expenditures but uh I
think that there are ways to uh address
for example
um you know some of the legislation
we're going to be talking about this
afternoon subcommittee there I think
there are one-time usages of funds that
would be more written thank you for the
questions
representative
a clarification I don't um for your
comments I must have missed that I don't
see where they said this is only one
time funds to the school
my question was whether it should be
used for one-time activities or
activities which are going to require
dollars in later years where we know
that the grant money is a one-time deal
but okay to clarify that then but in
this particular request it doesn't say
the school couldn't receive it annually
if they win right
that'd be great if they could get it
okay it's not a one-time request I guess
that's my point and
there's nothing here that stipulates
that the school can only get it once I
think it's just fishing you can't rely
on unless I missed it here it's it's
going to be money's appropriate for our
biennium so this thing is it an ongoing
deal for buying them after buying
anything I don't know I see what you
mean okay thank you
further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
is this type of program in place in
other schools I mean in other states
uh I'm aware of legislation that has
been filed in other states but uh I'm
not aware of other states that have a
program like this
further questions
thank you very much thank you are there
any other pink cards for this bill
not seeing it we will close the hearing
and move on to uh HB 371
establishing a commission to evaluate
and recommend standards for public
schools
representative Ludo you will take card
you can fill that out when you're done
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee for the record uh David
luno representing the people of
Merrimack County District 9
which are the towns of Hopkinton and
Beau
this um
this bill
um before you right now Hospital 371 uh
is um is is very timely and I'll get
into uh to exactly why that is but uh
but but before I get into that I want to
talk a little bit about well I want to
sort of set the stage as to um as to how
our public schools are doing how our our
public school students are doing across
the state and um you know before I was
on the um uh education committee I
didn't have a lot of
familiarity with the uh the nape scores
and our our state assessment
um uh tests and there have been some
changes over the last um uh handful of
years uh including what we use to uh to
uh assess how our students are doing at
the 11th grade now we're using the SAT
tests
um uh to do that but um but you know
going back quite a while New Hampshire
students perform among the best in the
um in the country and um uh but but
recently and when I talk about best in
the con among the best in the country
I'm talking about top five and I'm
talking Statewide I'm not saying every
student in every District or even the
average student in every district is
performing uh tops in the country but
Statewide are our average student
performance is uh is right up there uh
tops in the tops among uh among all
other states
during and and since the pandemic
um
um you know we've probably seen some
slippage
um in that and I think there are other
factors that that probably contributed
to has has contributed to that too such
as the number of new programs that have
been introduced over the last few years
that have so little accountability and
oversight that um that it's hard to tell
whether they're even relevant to uh to a
public education but um but even with
all that even with the pandemic even
with some of these unaccountable
um uh programs without any oversight our
kids are still way above the national
average and um and New Hampshire is
among a small number of states that uh
that that you know receive that
distinction uh in the uh in the on the
nape website and you can you know take a
look at look it up um naep and um and
it's it's also I think referred to by
the um by the U.S department of Ed as
the the nation's um report card and uh
and so our our on average our students
um perform really well
um the problem is it's just not
happening everywhere and um there is a
strong correlation and we learned this
in our study uh back in 2020. strong
correlation between how students are
performing and um and pockets of uh of
of families in uh with low income low
social economics uh situations and lack
of Community Resources and so um
a little policy
a booklet called policy points which I
think probably everybody received over
the last month or so and just put out
every um every couple years by the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
actually makes a uh makes a policy
um comment on this and uh and it says by
directing more resources to districts
with lower property values and students
with lower incomes the state could help
address issues of education and equity
which is student outcomes and strengthen
New Hampshire's Workforce future so you
can see how important how we go about
you know offering public education is
not only to our students and their
Futures but to our economy here in New
Hampshire and so um so
anyway the
um
how are public schools go about doing
their performing their jobs is uh is
tied closely with not only everything
that's in representative Tanner's law
book that that we all have in in front
of us but also the um uh implemented
through rules that are adopted by the
State Board of Education and uh and now
I'm really in an area where it's I'm I'm
you know I've never I've never taught in
the Public's I've never taught in a
school before I've been on a school
board
um I've never been an administrator in a
school uh so I'm really sort of coming
up to the edge of my um you know you
know my confidence in this area but I
believe a lot of these are called quote
the Ed rules and um and these are the
rules that that that the New Hampshire
Department of Education use for um for
um approving uh schools as public
schools in in in the state and I'm sure
although I don't have any any direct
knowledge of this but I'm sure over the
decades and decades and decades that
these rules have um have been developed
and evolved and changed over time to
reflect um uh maybe more you know under
you know how we go about understanding
how students learn what they need to
learn what's relevant to our economies
uh and things like that
um and um and currently my understanding
is that these rules are again in
um uh in the in the process of being
being being redeveloped uh looking at
certain things that are currently
requirements maybe re recategorizing
them as expectations and
um and I guess the big question is how
would or how will or how wood changes to
our our um our state's education rules
uh impact um students
and their outcomes not just on the nape
and SAT scores but in their outcomes as
um as as as
successful uh people uh in New Hampshire
and and in our economy and their
ability to uh to to to to contribute to
I think all the things that that we find
important in in our in our um in New
Hampshire and across the country so
um so
currently the the the changes I think
are being developed
um now but uh but not necessarily in in
full public View and not necessarily in
collab in a collaborative way with um
with stakeholders uh that may include I
think experts in uh in a number of
different fields but also also members
of the public and students
um who are obviously important
stakeholders in this um in this Mission
this committee by somebody sitting right
where I am now was promised several
weeks ago that we would have copies of
um of the draft standards and uh to date
I don't believe we have we have seen
anything
but but most importantly what house bill
371 does is really get to how you go
about
um
responsibly making uh making changes to
our Ed rules consistent with
all of the laws and and representative
Tanner's green law book
um that we all have uh in front of us
and uh and doing it in a way that that
meets the needs of of our students our
families and our economy
um and in a way that I that I hope
preserves the um or not preserved but is
consistent with uh with the tradition of
uh of Excellence that that we've had
here uh in terms of student outcomes in
New Hampshire uh over a long period of
time so uh so the bill
um is very straightforward in um and um
and now I'm I'm just on page one of the
bill I'm not going to go through it and
uh and agonizing detail but it basically
establishes a uh a commission to
evaluate and recommend the education
standards the rules used to um to
approve public schools and uh it
includes um a couple members of the
House one member of the Senate and then
you can sort of go down and see I'm sort
of in the middle of page one
um different
experts in the field of Education
whether they're teachers
um uh Behavioral Health practitioners
school counselors a nutrition director
administrators
and then over on page page two special
education Advocate a business
representative I know the representative
from the Bia on the school funding
commission was was very important and
had a very important role in in that
it's got a couple of parents got a
couple of students and um and among the
the responsibilities and how the
commission acts and I know this is very
important it acts as an independent
commission and uh and that means it's
it's independent of the legislature I
mean yeah it's got It's got three
legislators on it but but it's got It's
got stakeholders on it and it is not
being driven by by any um any any
political force it's independent of um
of that and then among its uh its charge
it includes a ref recommend a minimum
standards for uh Public School approval
I think that's the predominant one but
very important
that that it also considers you know
um you know other
um other input and and look at other
things that may be relevant uh to make
sure that uh that we've got some of the
or that we're among you know the best
um public schools in uh in the country
so um and providing our students with
those opportunities going on to uh to
page three at the top is a reporting
section uh where an initial a
preliminary report would would be
submitted to a number of different uh
um uh Folks by June 1st 2024 and final
report by November 1st 2027
and actually annual reports uh submitted
every year uh between 2024 and 2027 and
then uh finally the the entire process
would sunset on November 1st 2027
commensurate with that final report I
notice there's a there's an error in
on line 17 of Section 3 where Roman one
should say section two of this actual
take effect November 1st 2027 and for um
for uh um uh for new members to the the
legislature the way you do the way the
way we've we've traditionally done sun
setting is through a repeal provision so
that repeal provision provision is on
line 14 section 2 which repeals the
entire thing and uh in that part that
section two would not take into effect
until November 1st 2027 so that's um
that gives it the full you know life
cycle of of a creation establishment of
a study commission the work of the study
commission the deliverables of the study
commission and then the repeal uh once
that work is is done so I'm happy to
take some questions I I think there's a
there's um hopefully a few people that I
think probably have a lot more
experience in this area that where
anything detailed uh with respect to the
work that's being done right now by the
department
could be asked but I'll take what you
got here thank you I'll open up with one
question for you just to get some
clarification
is this about the minimum Public School
approval standards only or academic
standards because there's two types of
Standards which are approved by the
state board I don't see the academic
standards mentioned within so it's just
306. that's my that's that's the
intention of um of of this of this
correct thank you
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair it's all right I have
two questions they're different
um first question is we can refer to uh
page two line 17 where it states under
um commission shall uh it talks about
pre-kindergarten through grade 12. are
we are we suggesting here through this
that the commission is going to look to
expand the definition of an adequate
education from current things to include
pre-kindergarten
so so thanks for the question I think uh
I think the commission could certainly
be looking at that the state does have a
requirement to provide uh
pre-kindergarten for uh for certain
groups and um and uh and I think in in
with with with stipulation that uh that
that no more than 50 percent of the
students in a Pre-K uh program
um
uh can be can be not special education
students so so I think there may be some
people that can that can that can answer
that question in Greater detail than
that thank you and if I made it yeah the
second question uh referring same page
line 32 same it's talking about the
requirements of the commissioner what
they shall do it says promote within the
schools and the general population of
the state
implementation of the minimum standards
for public school approval I'm is this
talking about like a I don't know like a
messaging campaign to the population of
the state to get them on board with this
what are we talking about yeah I think
it's it's basically transparency that um
that that people in in New Hampshire
should be should be um I don't use this
word a lot but I think I should be proud
of our of our public schools and and
recognize the fact that we've got
minimum standards for school approval
that don't make it easy to uh to to run
a public school we've got school
administrators here with US
Representative Woodcock uh
representative cascaden and um and uh
you know I I I remember the
superintendent I'm sure Dr cascadden has
said this you know uh that schools
operate in a highly regulated
environment and um and um I think a lot
of that is there for Consumer Protection
um to make sure that uh that that
students are receiving the the the the
you know uh a public education that
relevant to our economy relevant to
their Futures and at a level that that
is that is going to put them you know in
an environment where they can learn and
uh and they can have strong outcomes if
I may just a very brief follow-up on
that
um because of course it's one thing to
present to have a commission that looks
at this stuff and present a report that
the general public can then look at it
but can you speak to the the propriety
of of doing something like a messaging
campaign to the general public to try to
get them on board with something
well I think it's it's it's it's it's
probably best done in contrast to what's
being done right now uh which is behind
closed doors
um uh like I said we still haven't
received a copy of a draft report that's
supposed to go before the State Board of
Education for review and approval and
who knows when but I I heard maybe even
um uh within the next number of weeks so
so we haven't seen anything right now
certainly I think work
um that's um that that is used to uh uh
Define Public School approval and what
two billion dollars of public property
taxpayer three billion dollars total of
of New Hampshire uh taxpayer money goes
to support it should uh it should be
done with um uh out there where people
can see it and uh people eyes wide open
know what's uh know what's going on
thank you further questions
yes represent Balboni
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um since I'm new here so I'm going to
ask a pretty basic question I I think
um how are the standards currently
updated and who is currently involved in
doing it
so thank you thank you very much for the
uh for the question I think there's
probably people that follow
um that that can that can that can
better answer that question uh just just
uh at a at a high high level
um I believe my understanding is that
the Department of Education has
contracted with a consultant to uh to
manage that um you know the whole
operation and beyond that I really don't
um uh know how it's being done it's
certainly not being done in a way that's
uh that's been
transparent or um you know or
collaborative
thank you
got a question I'm looking at the
commission makeup
he ran out of letters in the alphabet uh
when you were doing just about but
um of course that's pretty unwieldy 25.
yeah would you would you believe I
actually got uh got a response from some
of this of why why am I not on the
haven't I've been named to the
commission too right and it's somebody
that said that comes into this committee
quite a bit you've indicated a lot of
different organizations
but you've neglected to include the
community college system of New
Hampshire or even the university system
New Hampshire which are teacher
preparation programs and you know that's
where they come from
yeah no thank thanks thanks very much
representative Ladd I I I I I I
wholeheartedly agree with you that um
that that that that
both the community colleges and I I
chair of one of the Community College
boards
um and I'm gonna I'm on a University of
New Hampshire board as well and uh that
that they are absolutely stakeholders in
this uh in this Mission and and they
feel firsthand and as as as as we you
know learned a couple weeks ago with the
uh with the math uh communities bill
um firsthand if um if schools aren't
able to um uh to to do their jobs
um uh in a way that that brings students
onto college campus where they're ready
to learn math at a college level uh so
um so I I absolutely agree with with
your thoughts on this further questions
yes representative Tanner thank you for
bringing this bill forward and I also
want to comment on the fact that the
commission does have a tremendous range
of stakeholders uh maybe even adding the
college and Community College system uh
as that could you comment on uh how
unwielding a large commission like this
might be or might not be
and what kind of results comes from a
large commission like this based on your
experiences
so thanks thanks for the question
um the the commission that concluded in
this report
um uh for uh for school funding uh was a
was a one-year commission and um and we
had 17 members
um on that commission including
representative zlad and Miler and
cascadden
um uh from from this room and um
and
to be to be completely honest when we uh
when we when we started out uh we were
we we met in uh in January we started
meeting in January of 2000 and we met in
the finance room room 210
um and uh 2 11 212. yeah down at the end
everybody knows where it is and um and
and you really needed that type of um
that type of size to what to to uh uh to
do that we had a number of people that
would would attend these uh these
commission meetings as well because of
the obviously the Statewide importance
of the work that that we were doing as
well as the work that this commission
would do uh during the pandemic
um we we uh switched over to uh to uh
Zoom for uh for the balance of the
meetings from uh I think end of March
right through when the the Committees
work was is done in on December 1st 2000
and and from a management standpoint I
chaired that committee it was I I felt
it was easier to do to to conduct
business uh via Zoom but probably
because I also got used to that uh as
well and zoom gives uh gives you some
you know meeting management tools that
that helps it to move along it also uh
allowed I think a tremendous
participation uh from from various
stakeholders across the state whether
they're superintendents building
administrators teachers parents
members of different school boards
advisory councils and things like that
to be able to watch the meeting and also
contribute through public comment and um
and while while none of that management
uh detail is specified in the in the
bill I don't think there's there's
anything that would necessarily prevent
a committee or commission from from
meeting in a in a hybrid mode much like
what what we're what we're doing in
these in these meetings so that at least
from a from a transparency standpoint uh
the public would be able to uh to see
government in action
further questions representative thank
you Mr chair I'd just like to make one
comment on the independent nature of the
commission for the committee's sake
since we have new people here there is
uh the other option is to have a
legislative committee
and the legislative committee would
would only involve at the table
legislators and the problem with that I
believe especially in something like
this is that the only way you get voices
from other groups is through testimony
by having an independent Commission
you include those voices at the table
and that is a major change in how you
would conduct the business here and I
think when a reference that
representative luno talked about the
school funding commission that was the
intent of that was we wanted to get
those voices that are directly involved
in this at the table and not just giving
a testimony then walking away that
they're engaged in it so I I would
commend your independent nature on this
because I think this is important as you
begin to look at standards
um there's no question here but that as
you begin to look at standards having
voices at the table that are involved in
implementing those standards I think
it's very important and thank you for
bringing this forward thank you
representative are there further
questions representative
thank you very much president was I'm
assuming um that the information or I
want to be sure uh
is this your intent that these
commission meetings will be open to the
public oh absolutely thank you
further questions
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr chair uh Sarah Robinson
everyone how are we doing
um Mr chair thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak to all of you today
uh my name is Sarah Robinson I'm the
education Justice campaign director for
Granite State progress I'm also a school
board member for the Concord School
District though I am here in my capacity
as an individual and not on behalf of
the district I'm a graduate of New
Hampshire Public Schools and also a
parent to two Elementary school-aged
children who attend our local public
school I am here as a strong supporter
of quality education and as a parent and
I am asking that you vote HB 371 as
ought to pass
the 306 rules which representative Muno
mentioned touch on every aspect of a
student's Public School experience from
the lunch that they will eat in the
school cafeteria to the professional
development their Educators receive and
literally everything in between
currently our department of education is
undergoing the process of revisiting
those rules
um in a way that has been opaque and
exclusive of public oversight and
participation meetings and minutes are
not easily accessible the draft of the
rules and process are shared only with a
narrow group of people and are
inaccessible to parents and students
our organization is one of many that
signed a letter which was presented to
the State Board of Ed asking for a halt
or revision of the 306 process
HB 371 would correct the errors of the
process currently underway the suggested
participants as listed in the bill which
we were talking about it's a large group
of people but it is inclusive and it is
mindful in particular the inclusion of
parents and students as a parent of two
Elementary school-aged kiddos
I've been dismayed in the lack of
availability of the process and the
ability for my voice to be a part of
this critical decision-making process
this bill would certainly give myself
and other parents across the state the
assurance that our concerns and more
importantly the experiences are are
excuse me experiences of our students
are being taken seriously it also allows
for a timeline that would enable enable
public participation in an observation
of the process
HB 371 affords us an opportunity to do
right by our public school system in a
way that has been lacking over the past
several years strong public education
requires a strong Foundation which is
what these rules can provide please show
New Hampshire families that you care
about quality education and strong
public schools by voting OTP on HP 371.
thank you yeah are the questions from
the committee
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and for your work could you
just detail a little bit about
your organization and others efforts to
follow the current process and what the
barriers have been yeah of course so I
have the privilege of being able to
attend State Board of Education meetings
and to watch the rules process as it
develops many rules processes like for
Holocaust and genocide education were
really well done very publicly open
everybody had access to understand the
way the process was going and to watch
the development of those rules which
were very successful this however the
306 rules has deviated from that
standard in a way that I don't know what
the Draft rules look like I as a parent
or just a layperson being able to access
this process via the Doe's website is
very cumbersome it is not up front it
requires a lot of digging
and parents and students from what I am
aware of or not at the table for this
conversation and I think that's a very
critical voice that's not being included
and I don't know that there are plans
for that to happen outside of the Normal
public hearing process through the State
Board of Ed I'd like to see those voices
Incorporated before we get to the final
stages of these really critical rules
that dictate how public education
functions in our state
further questions
yep
thank you Mr chair
could you also please share with us what
you know about the presence of Educators
at different levels on that existing uh
effort
so I do know that the doe has had
conversations with Educators I believe
there's been one or two meetings again
it's not a very transparent process so
I'm I don't have the full scope of what
those conversations look like I don't
know what educators are at that table I
trust that folks involved in the process
do have the best intentions for our
students but without the public being
able to fully know and easily access
that information we don't know what we
don't know I hope that answers your
question experience thank you for the
questions from the committee thank you
very much okay thank you very much for
the opportunity and we'd like to invite
David Trumbull
good morning good morning
thank you for having me my name is David
Trumbull I'm from the town aware
representing myself I support this bill
for the reasons that were already stated
but I'll go into a little bit of detail
I just want to be honest I am not able
to access all the information but what
I've been able to have learned I will
use I support this bill for three
reasons first it's open and transparent
government just like this committee here
you have hearings people citizens
Educators parents come in when you
deliberate we can watch it online from
home there's a public record there's
back and forth with the current DOA plan
there is none of this there's no public
minutes there's no public meetings
there's no back and forth if you look at
your local school boards those are
elected officials parents Educators
people who work in the schools go in and
testify or speak at their public school
board meetings it goes from the school
board the superintendent in the back and
there's back and forth it's open the
commission that representative luno
described with school funding same thing
on Zoom well attended that's good
government when you have a chance to
hear from people the citizens have a
right to participate and the parents
rights are respected there's been a lot
of discussion about parents rights and
education in this session from both
sides and if you believe in parents
rights you would want to have education
rules that are being debated in public
so that everybody knows what's going on
there's no way that you can say I'm for
parents rights on education Freedom
accounts but you don't care about the
rules being drafted their parents not
having an input so I think basically
what's happening is doe is trying to
legislate in secret and that's not good
governments even if you like the results
of what they come up with you wouldn't
want that to be the process by which our
system runs second reason I like this
bill is it's it's not really that the
main issue but it does mention the term
adequacy if you look at the the
commission shall number Roman numeral 3B
determine whether the current minimum
standards provide the opportunity for
for an adequate education for all
students pre-k through 12. we need data
on adequacy WE debate whether or not the
property poor towns are able to
adequately educate their children
this bill will have this commission look
at that and get you some data so when
those bills come up in the next
legislature and the one after that
you'll be able to look at it and say
Here's the educational results
throughout the state you can line up the
towns from property poor to property
Rich towns and compare the results and
you'll see that correlation that
representative linole talked about but
you'll have the hard data to then be
able to make good decisions about how to
implement the Claremont decision and I
would also ask you to look at I I was
able to look at A draft copy online of
this bill of the doe regs but in three
30606 B1 what they do is eliminate
looking at Equity gaps in achievement
and instead look at the quote
underperformance of individual students
so in other words the idea that Equity
that the problem is that there's a
equity gap between Property Port Towns
and property Rich towns that's going to
be like eliminated from our nomenclature
and now it's individual students are
underperforming so it's their fault that
they're not doing well in a town that
can't provide them their resources so
just the philosophical difference
between what representative luno's Bill
proposes which is to say let's look at
the data as opposed to we're eliminating
the concept of equity from the question
completely I think this would be a good
reason why you would want to have this
bill so you can get the data to make
good decisions as you do your work over
time
the third reason I support the bill is
that it protects the civil and
educational rights of the students that
the
copy that I looked at of this new 306
has several areas of concern to me one
is in 30604 J it adds personal learning
plans for every student but there's no
explanation of how that interacts with
IEPs and 504 plants does it replace them
with this personal learning plan and
what exactly are the rules governing
that it also takes out in
30604j the duty to look at the
instructional needs of each student
based on a number of things including
their development so it looks like it
weakens the rights for special ed
students but there's nothing clearly
stating it there clearly we need to know
what they're doing at DOD this bill by
comparison says that we want to promote
a inclusive learning environment at all
public schools around the state so
clearly this bill says special ed
students we're keeping you covered the
current doe regulations it's not clear
the second thing is competencies in 3060
4b25 it takes out a dozen competencies
no longer it just completely removes the
whole section competencies on Arts
digital literacy English math physical
science biological science New Hampshire
and U.S history New Hampshire and U.S
government Civics economics personal
finance world history geography health
and physical education all those things
are removed in the new 306.
is this a backdoor approach to basically
hollowing out the public schools that
parents can get together with their
children put together a bundled plan to
go do what they want to do but at the
end of the day they don't know English
and math and history that's ridiculous
we should have competency standards that
make sense like Professor uh
representative luno testified we have a
great school system in the state why
would you want to tear down something
that's working and eliminate
competencies in all of these basic areas
so children by the time they're in
seventh grade could just leave the
public school go do what they want to do
and nobody cares if they know anything
about history or math or geography that
that doesn't make any sense so this bill
would make sure that doesn't happen a
third area I'm concerned about is lgbtq
students this this bill talks about an
inclusive learning environment however
in the proposed draft 30606 A4 it takes
out protected classes for race ethnicity
and gender and replaces it with a
language saying any and all stereotypes
and biases now now you could say well
any and all would include everything but
we all know that a general phrasing of
any and all isn't worth much if you're
in a protected class you want to have
your class specifically mentioned I mean
just consider that we had to pass the
Civil Rights Act to make sure black
people could vote in this country women
were denied the right to vote lgbtqp
will need its same-sex marriage you need
to have specific legislation or else
people who are in these protected
classes lose their rights the proposed
regulations weaken that we don't know
what the impact would be but it could be
very detrimental and it's worth pointing
out that as of today according to the
CDC 22 percent of high school students
identify as lgbtq so you're talking
about one in every five students who may
lose rights under the new doe rules the
last issues is the discipline policy the
regs in 30606 B2 completely removes
the system that says we will establish
right now this is the status quo we
establish a fair and Equitable code of
discipline that is fairly inconsistently
implemented so they're getting rid of
the code of discipline that is fair and
Equitable fairly and consistently
implemented so what difference does that
make if you're a student of color or if
you're a student with a disability you
are disciplined much more dramatically
than people who are not so I'll just
give you a few statistics to finish up
here in the car seat School of public
policy at UNH did a report called the
exclusionary discipline highest in New
Hampshire Urban schools what they say is
that exclusive exclusionary discipline
affects 11 to 12 percent of students
between grades eight to twelve so this
is a lot of students over 10 percent of
our students either get in-school
suspension or out of school suspension
but who does it affect they looked at
the length of exclusion for students of
color it's over two times greater for in
school and 2.7 times greater for out of
school they looked at students with
disabilities for non-disabilities with
no disabilities the rate is from one to
five percent for those with disabilities
it's from 11 to 51 in other words
students with disabilities and students
of color get disciplined more often and
it's
doctor monitor did a report from the
reported on our study from the Juvenile
Justice Reform project that set students
of color in New Hampshire twice as
likely to be disciplined students of
color with disabilities over five times
as likely to be disciplined in their
study after study going on and saying
the same thing for basically the same
behaviors and usually it's just for
minor infractions the American
Psychological Association did a report
called for black students unfairly harsh
discipline can lead to lower grades 26
percent of black students compared to
only two percent of white students were
suspended for minor infractions that's
like dress code and using your cell
phone in class so the result is it
impacts people dramatically so if they
eliminate this entire Clause from the
306 rules there's nothing in place the
rules that says we have to have a fair
and impartial discipline policy but
these are all things that would come out
if they had an open discussion if they
let the public participate if they head
back and forth with people if they
invited people in rather than excluding
people from making the rules they're
trying to legislate from a little room
with a small group of people what you're
doing here every single day is the right
way to do it and that's why I support
this bill
thank you thank you very much Mr
Trumbull are there any questions from
the committee represent Belcher thank
you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony I just wanted to clarify the
the draft uh rules those are on the
State website I uh found them through a
non-profit education organization that
had a link to them and I looked at them
this morning so I I don't know uh why
you don't have them and I was able to
look at them today but
so you don't know if they're on the
State website it was not uh I'm sorry I
don't have my laptop with me and I I'm
just not from but I mean it was I would
have printed it but it was so long it
would have been 100 pages and I really
didn't have time to do that this morning
but it's clearly 306 and it's you know
etched out in red and crossed out and
replaced with this so it's it's it's
it's the real thing I don't know where I
don't I have that data for you but I
think you should have access to that if
I can look at it everybody here should
have access to that sure thank you yeah
further questions from the committee
people
yes representative Woodcock thank you
chairman uh Mr the testimony you escaped
particularly with some of the citations
you made
um is that going to be submitted to the
clerk or could you forward an email
because some of those I'd like to look
at sure if I send it to you by email
would that be sufficiently
to the whole committee yeah thank you so
much
I will do that that's that's all
handwritten right now yeah yeah no no
don't do that no no can you just you
have a PDF or you know make make a copy
of it I'll type something up and then
send it to you tonight uh we don't want
you have to do all that yeah no you
could you can scan and take a photo of
it and then take a photo then you can
send that attachment to
to us all right I will send you
something today
[Laughter]
all right okay uh are there further
questions
not see any thank you very much thank
you are there any other folks that have
pink cards
just sit down and all right sorry my
son's back there so I'm gonna throw it
out there introduce yourself for the the
record please sure my name is Christina
pretorius I am the policy director with
reaching higher New Hampshire
and to answer that that previous
question
um that draft is available on the
reaching higher website
um it is a draft that was made available
on January 13th of this year
I I think I I heard the question it it's
not on the doe website uh to my
understanding uh it is not
okay further questions of Christine
thank you very much
oh yeah uh I think uh by May uh
would it be appropriate for this
committee
to have a chance to have whoever is
drafting these 306 rules which are
critical to education
to come before this committee and have a
chance to hear what in fact what's going
on I mean Mr Trimble has probably he has
given us more information about these
306 rules than we've ever heard before
and it's foundational to the future of
Education I mean is that something I I
realize we've got a very full agenda
here but on the other hand this is
critical to what's we've had Department
of Education here and they've indicated
that they would be provided to us within
a period of time
um I think that's what we're waiting for
if in fact they they do not arrive here
within you know a certain time that's
you know not too far out from here
because we're supposed to have them
right now if not then we can contact
them and have them come and present that
what they're going to present to the
State Board of Education to this
committee as well
thank you I I look forward to that that
session
further further discussion on this bill
from the committee okay thank you very
much this hearing is closed
and we'll break for lunch and we'll come
back
uh right right around 1 15.
foreign
yes um thank you
um so
yeah
don't ask me
okay thank you
do I need the microphone on yeah okay
good okay
um so you know we did seek to broaden it
based on feedback from superintendents
um this past uh year we had a number of
instances where superintendents applied
for example for uh an a one-year
certificate for a school librarian or a
digital learning specialist and they
they're not eligible under the way that
the current statute was is written and
the proposal initially
yes yeah logical I think
I could also mention chair I forward you
an email this morning from
superintendent Ron Hasbrouck in Groveton
supporting the bill
um and that was a result of my meeting
with the North Country superintendents
on Thursday uh morning I was up uh in
Whitefield at their meeting and they
were very excited about this bill
um same thing the day before I was at
the Lakes Region superintendent's
meeting there was also some excitement
in that room as well with this bill I
asked
both groups if you have comments please
email me and I'll forward them to the
chair
um so far I've received that one it's
okay
thanks 12 to 14 I don't think that's
anywhere a change
um on the amendment
a B and C are also just as they were in
law
and then we have 1A is same as it was
two Roman two
Roman 3
Roman 3A
is I think that's the same as it was
introduced
and line Roman 4 23
changing the educator again teacher
educator license to teacher you know
and so those are the changes
that we have do you have any other
changes this for this Steve
you know I I think this this
that change from teacher to educator I
think will again assist the field a
great deal
okay
so let's have a little discussion on the
mentoring of
no it's not but we had that discussion
before and so I I thought I heard people
saying you know is there a need for
to have a mentor sometimes it costs
money to have a mentor
um uh maybe it's just that person next
door and they work collaboratively
together and it's just you know part of
the job
the administrator the supervisor
is there
need to further amend this thing
are we ready to move on
okay
just one question yeah yeah rather than
a benefit
rather than just talking about Mentor in
a general sense I'm wondering some of
the programs that I'm familiar with we
have people who've been Paris for six or
eight years and they decide they want to
move to a teacher's thing and they have
the bachelor's degree and so then that
sometimes when the school is in need of
someone they turn to this provision and
say
you know we'd like you to teach for a
year or something like that and and in
those instances we recommend they don't
use this law for those Powers so when
districts contact us about that that
type of scenario we recommend they don't
use this law that instead they put that
person on our site-based licensing path
which provides the mentorship and a
development plan and gives them three
years to gain their teacher license
um because those folks have experience
and they already hold a power start so
I I'm I'm glad to hear that and I'm
familiar with at least one individual
who had a bachelor's degree in teaching
English
as a foreign language from a university
in Hong Kong and the school is unclear
as to whether or not they could use a
degree from Hong Kong and they weren't
as tightly conversant with the
organization that certifies foreign
degrees out of Boston and so sometimes
it takes a little bit more to the
equation to make it all add up yeah
thank you we we do have information in
our knowledge base on our website that
directs individuals of foreign
transcripts to contact us so we can
connect them with the Boston
organization that you mentioned okay so
uh certainly if there's a district if
you think of the district and I can be
of help happy to to reach out okay thank
you
okay is there further need to discuss
this bill no okay let's let's because we
have some others which are going to be I
think a lot more
any order you want let's do this 623
since speed was involved yes okay good
623 established a teacher candidate loan
forgiveness program
representative lad you have an extra
copy of that bill
yeah I can look
we had an amendment to it yeah the
amendment is really the focus point
s
that was your Amendment
for teaching I mean rural or a high need
districts that it's a long reimbursement
maybe what we need to do is try to see
if we can round up
Jen is there any way we can find get a
copy of 623 the original as introduced
and then the amendment we had an
amendment
um I've got to copy that here
if anybody needs a bill well Steve will
okay
get a copy Amendment yeah yeah
you got both patients of the amendment
no I just need the amendment oh the
amendment
right here Jen oh you got one over there
okay
I need the amendment
thank you
Lindsay doesn't work on Mondays Fridays
no she's doing me she's doing me yeah
yeah later on it better be me my wife's
making a quilt for a baby quilt and
it'll be for Missouri quilt gets his ass
you want to move on and talk about uh
yeah she'll be back real quick and just
right down the hallway here
foreign
problems
yes there's a note to everybody here
um we we did discuss when we're going to
be taking up 529
and do the fact we have the governor
presenting tomorrow and it's our
understanding there may be discussion
within that presentation of school
funding
um so rather than executing this on the
15th the day after the governor That's
History we're going to wait and do it on
the 16th first thing in the morning
it's already been put in the docket
where we can do that where bills were
executing on the 16th it states
basically continued executive executive
session on any remaining bills from
February the 15th so it's scheduled for
the 15th we just won't deal with it in
the 15th we'll wait and do it on the
16th can we do it
after the uh the hearings on the 16th so
that we do have any language we need to
work on we can
um
yeah
rather than first thinking
yeah we're gonna have to make sure
though that
we're gonna have to hustle through those
those hearings
um
because we're gonna we'll take our first
thing in the afternoon first thing
foreign
on the 20th
we won't
that's President's Day
um
that's the week before the spring break
it's probably going to be a pretty busy
week I would say
uh what I got to do is as soon as uh I
get a hold of Lindsay when she comes in
tomorrow and next day I want to find out
how many bills we've already heard how
many of we already exact what do we have
left
if we have a large number still to here
and some of the ones we have to hear are
bills which are going to
draw
okay I think we're ready to go ahead
you know when you walk us through
represent myler's 623 Amendment yeah the
amendment
excuse me the amendment replaces the
original bill
and it changes it significantly from a
standpoint of uh how the loan
reimbursement would take place we've had
some conversation here in the committee
about the concern about
the Forgiveness of loans in general
but I think what this is trying to do is
to say okay if you're going to go work
in a rural District or in an area where
there is at-risk not at risk
under-resourced needs like math science
and and Steve this is what I need to be
here my understanding is that the
department does talk about under
improving uh underperforming schools as
well as those uh High need
teacher areas math science
Etc CTE Etc and so it's to try to
provide an opportunity for schools out
of our our out of our teacher shortage
work group for schools to say okay look
if you come teach here if you want to
come to teach here in Littleton here's
what we can do for you we can provide we
can apply and get part of your tuition
reimbursed and again you note that the
reimbursement
accelerates based upon the number of
years you're in the district so it
starts out at fifteen hundred then
twenty five hundred thirty five hundred
forty total of twelve thousand dollars
that they say and that my theory here
may be wrong but if we can get people
stay in a district
when they finish that fourth year
hopefully they're going to stay in that
District because they will have
commitments they may have you know maybe
purchased a home or have got
relationships in the community so it
really is it's very similar to the uh to
the ndea loans that uh at least maybe
representative uh Ford in Ladd and
myself since we're the oldest folks here
in this uh on this group I know
the federal government provided in the
late 60s provided this kind of this kind
of a thing to incentivize folks to teach
and uh so I think that was kind of in
the back of my mind as I looked at the
original bill says now that doesn't
really deal with it this really I think
is much more focused on on what it's all
about so that's kind of the that's the
intent of it anyway
can we go back and discuss first of all
how you selected the
rule underperforming School educator
rural School District underperforming
school
um
so
um yes it is hard if your rule in
geographically isolated
to attract
it's hard to attract if you don't have
the property base or the salary level to
compete against the wealthy District
and of course if you have an
underperforming School
achievement wise
do these categories captured the three
areas I just mentioned yeah
the low income which one does that well
well I'm assuming that some of your
rural schools are going to be in
are not going to be as wealthy as your
uh some of the other districts service
so you have rule like Waterville Valley
no
disadvantages
yeah
so that yeah
well Waterville Valley would qualify as
a rural School District yes it would
you only have to have one of those
offices
I think it's the word or
yeah so I yeah that that word or makes
it any of the three
um and I the only other issue I would
say with Rural and maybe it's just an
elimination of a solves it but I the way
that this is you know I wouldn't want to
see a city school
potentially
be be left out I think that we discussed
I'm going to disclose this curtain I
can't see the paper but I wonder if just
removing rural altogether and using B
and C
might accomplish the same thing with
less confusion
say that again eliminate a
I'm sorry page two line three okay
well you you just you would look at B
and C now is qualifiers B or C but you
would take out a so Waterville Valley if
they don't qualify under B or C then it
doesn't matter that they're rural
are there some rule though that that
might have a hard time hiring teachers
that aren't B and C but aren't
Waterville Valley
you know
you know they're not economically
disadvantaged they're not
underperforming but they but they're so
rural that they
don't have a hard time getting teachers
to stay or I don't know do you not do
you know yeah I I mean I think that
there are
foreign
but it's my sense in talking to
superintendents that some of the the
shortage areas really cut across
geography and and economics you know
math science special ed those really
doesn't seem the only determining Factor
seems to be the districts that pay the
most for those get those folks
it doesn't necessarily come down to
you know Pittsburgh can't hire them but
Concord can due to geography it seems
really to be much more compensation yeah
one of the reasons why rural was in here
that that was one of the issues that we
dealt with in the teacher shortage work
group that we had that there was a
concern about that so
um that was what comes to say that's why
that was in there that term was used
quite a bit
I would suggest that we turn that phrase
around a little bit an underperforming
School educator
you see where the adjective goes it
makes the teacher underperforming not
the school
well the kids were concerned about
they might want to rephrase that anyway
you're talking about item uh line eight
just to use line three words yeah but it
did line three and ax
establishing to talk to me
underperforming School educator and said
that we're trying to enter incentivize
underperforming teachers
it should just be a educator in an
underperforming School
yeah it picks up down there yeah uh
line eight that too yeah it's consistent
throughout every time you hit you do it
you want a most School educator up in
front of underperforming have
underperforming in front of the of
school
it's just the phrase I'm not the son of
a substantial point
one thing that concerns me about this is
um not everybody graduated from a New
Hampshire school and you may have
teachers you want to retain who
graduated from a school in another state
and we don't I don't know how we can
waive their loans
because it doesn't come out of our
budget well these these grants are
coming out of our imaginary school
education yeah
okay so we just go to them as a grant
not as a payoff for all that to well
that that's going to get down into some
of the other questions we have
do we pay them as they go or do we pay
them after they've been in the state
five years
or or so they don't leave yeah that
defines it too
stay in the anticipation of getting the
money in four years hopefully
so
Steve do you have we we discussed this
on the teacher shortage committee
and there was this discussion uh
do we give a loan out right at the
beginning or do we hold off and or it's
done differently from state to state
isn't it
yes it is and it seems just again very
very loose anesthetical discussions I've
had with counterparts around the country
that the yearly is a much more
attractive
um set up than a lump sum at the end
um you know if we say and you know four
years from now you're gonna get twenty
five thousand dollars four years a long
way away and legislatively a lot can
happen in that time
so uh it seems better I've heard of more
success doing it on an annual basis okay
um
are doing
I would say the majority of them are
oh sorry so I'm comparing this document
that Brian Hawkins from Nea did of what
the other states are doing
and it looks like a majority of them are
at least this amount of money if not
more
and almost all of them are yearly
not cumulative at the end but pay as you
go basically
at least the way I read it anyway
[Music]
um where it says in the beginning the
doe shall identify the schools and then
it goes into rural isolation does that
mean right at the beginning while you
know one two three
um does that mean so let's say if it
were a Waterville Valley could they say
you know they are rule but they're not
economically disadvantaged
is it all schools at Fitness or the doe
decide
yes there were no
on the Waterville Valley
well I think thank you I think the
current way that it's written it would
be its or
or so they just have to meet one of the
three to qualify so if they meet number
one they're in the way that it's
currently written
that was the what I was wondering
well clearly the intent here is not
it is to deal with those who are having
a difficult time in hiring teachers
your your example of Waterville Valley I
I don't know I hadn't thought about that
Rick that's a good point I'm not sure
that they have a problem in hiring
teachers in Waterville Valley or not um
but that was the intent
um
and again we talked about the rural
isolation as being a problem of
Recruitment and I think your
superintendents would also concur that
that has been a problem particularly as
you deal with those in the North country
or those way over in the north east the
Northeast part of the state and even the
Southwest part of the state
well it's very expensive to have rural
will be the focus
so I wouldn't want page two would be and
so it's not just rural
well I think that's one of the pro I
mean one of the things we found that is
one problem the other problem is those
where you have uh High need teaching
areas that are that are hard to recruit
and I think I I don't I frankly think
that that's somewhat comparable uh it's
not either an either or kind of a
situation
they based it on poverty on if if the
town had a certain level of poverty you
could possibly tie it to three and
reduced formation
well I assume you have to have we want
to have to have standards for all for
all three of these if it's rural schools
it's going to be a stand what's a rural
school there's no other school within 25
miles or there's there's a definition on
that talking about but okay perhaps yes
rural School small rural School
this thing's going down the tubes
um and why I say that is we had a bill
dealing with geographic location and all
that way back in the years that Emma
Rouse was chair
and Senator Lou dalzandro was the one
who climbed all over us saying well I'm
going to start having small schools in
in Manchester
because we have the poverty we have the
need but now you're saying it's got to
be geographically isolated or a small
school out in the hinterland so I think
we've got to be very careful here that
we do hit the places where poverty
exists it may be in the middle of a city
well that's not a track that's one of
the reasons why it's talked about
economic disadvantage that that that I
would think with the poverty piece yeah
because that was clearly one of the
issues too so somebody mentioned earlier
well could a city school get some of
this yes they could based upon uh the
definition here of uh of economic
disadvantage
Mel does that require you to define the
road the urban school it's
underperforming well I I again I'm
relying somewhat on the department in
their definitions uh Oliver uh I didn't
want to get into
the total definitions in the law because
that's why it was really defers to the
Departments
definition of you know need and uh
disadvantage Etc because I think Steve
shaken has said yes they do do that so
that that they would be yeah they would
be the ones that that would uh maybe
we'll have to have that tag put around
their neck do they
when you say that that underperforming
or
every year and it doesn't come out of my
division so I'm only remotely familiar
um but I I mean you know for example the
nape scores right I know we do all kinds
of assessment testing right and we
bucket schools based on scores so of um
I'm relatively certain there's a
mechanism here that we identify these
schools do that yeah okay
yeah
just go ahead so
the first page defines rural isolation
and it defines underperformed School
but I don't see
definition of economic disadvantage
except on the page two line four where
they talk about related to Title One
so my question would be is that adequate
definition of economic disadvantage to
encompass
City Schools like Manchester or
Claremont
if they didn't qualify well Karma will
qualify and be underperforming but
I may ask my coder at my peer director
who oversees Title One if that works
sorry
so it's this
um
it's this is that sufficient enough to
to
so Title One funds are distributed based
on the U.S Census Bureau poverty
identification so if
that's where you'd want to identify then
I'd say that that's okay I know there's
been a lot of discussion with other
pieces of legislation about that
determination because it's i i a U.S
Census Bureau determination versus
actual poverty numbers it's not free and
reduced numbers so there's you're not
you're you're going to miss that
component that that population and it
may
not be the way you want to go I it's
just it's just determine basically on
what you'd want to accomplish with it
so all schools are going to receive a
title 1 allocation
just the amount that is utilized is
going to be dependent upon those uh U.S
Census Bureau numbers
so if I'm understanding what you're
saying then if all schools are getting
some amount of Title One
no way no all schools don't get Title
One all leas yes leas yes but that's
what she's saying schools correct
thank you for the distinction
and since that's based on Census Bureau
data does that mean it only changes
every 10 years
correct
I think they also take into account
um data that is reported at that county
level
or at that time level but it's a
different set of numbers compared to the
free and reduced and that's a different
program that's U.S department of
Agriculture so that's going to be a
different
determination
so I don't know if you want to go with
free and reduced
ignoring the U.S census sometimes is
very very misleading especially if
you're doing it by county
um the area I live in Grafton county is
poverty but if you look at Grafton
County it's the second highest you know
income area in the state because of
Hanover Lebanon and Plymouth but when
you get to Warren and rumney and Benton
and all those others it's low so if
you're going to have
and that's it free and reduced in that
particular school district is a better
identifier I believe than using the U.S
census
and this is going to be determined by
school
yeah so it has to do with a teacher
teaching in a school that meets one of
those criteria getting some enrollments
so you could have an instance where you
had a district
um let's say that has
a title one allocation coming in at the
Lea level so they might determine okay
we have you know three elementary
schools a middle school and a high
school we are going to use our entire
entire Title One allocation to focus on
the two of the elementary schools and
then we'll put all the funds towards
supporting that area as opposed to
putting any towards the middle or the
high school so it's really a local
decision
so when it um and looking at this a
little bit closer
basing it on the school
and the determination for title one may
not
be what you're hoping to accomplish you
might use a different what if we took
another way rather than try to define
the deficiency just say schools
identified by the Department of
Education as facing exceptional
challenges of various kinds maybe we
just let you decide make it official no
no no no no no that so wishy-washy
criteria that's going to be abused be
everybody yeah it'll be it and yet when
we changed from No Child Left Behind and
rewrote our rules for Essa one of the
things we are looking at is title one we
found out of the high schools how many
high schools at that time were receiving
Title One you could count them on a hand
very very few because the money the
resources were geared down to the grade
schools
so where Title One money s is not a good
way to do this either I don't believe
I'd rather do it where
especially if we're going to have a good
idea where the F and R is
and that we basically do I think have a
pretty good idea the number of
qualifiers in a school and I would do it
by
I don't know I'd rather do it by
district is awkwardly for for allocation
of the dollars
to attract the leas hiring these people
not the school
but the the local district is one that's
hurting
so use F and R and piggybacking on that
that does sound like using f r is a
better measure than using the title one
but I've been wondering especially if we
do use fnr we've talked about the fact
that we don't see as many kids on the
high school level that that
documentation is completed but in my
districts the high schools would
definitely have teachers who
they have teacher shortages that should
be addressed so
I think they do a new webinar for the
district not when we had the finance
deal we were putting together and we're
doing the slide for those which like 12
1.2 million 1.4 million down then there
was a little added on that I put in
there trying to give those schools above
that that had Title One there was going
to be a little extra given to them but
doe couldn't come across with that as
readily for us right
I guess either way if you're looking at
free and reduced numbers or you're
looking at title one allocations and if
we're looking at Distributing it at the
Lea level I mean
you're going to be looking at Manchester
Concord Nashua
those are great because because they
have some of the largest I'm just
picking up like the top three because
they have the largest population
so therefore they automatically receive
the highest allocation
because they're serving a higher number
of students
but I think you could also
Rick I think I think you could do it
using
and I'm sort of I sort of hesitate uh
referring specifically to free
introduced price launch if we could just
do that one place in the law and then
refer to
um
you know because that that may change
down the road with with direct
certification
and um
you know but if you could if we could
refer to
the um
you know the department the department
keeps the the uh you know has the the
ratio of of free and reduced price lunch
to to the total number to the total ADM
yeah and just set a cut line somewhere
I think you could do that I also think
you need to do that something to the
fact that Pittsburgh for example
who wants to move to Pittsburgh where if
you've been to the General Store up
there you're going to find all the
prices are double although gasoline's
cheaper in Pittsburgh than it is in
Haverhill
uh but you know it's isolated and you
can't have access to a university or a
college the way you can if you're living
down in Plymouth
so where I've lived before and I've
lived in some very rural areas
that you probably don't want to see the
only way to get there was by boat or by
plane and those were truly
geographically isolated and we gave a
huge bonus to people even come work
there
um
that's different than this state's
pretty small
we do have rural areas we have a hard
time attracting to but it's not like
some other states that like in the
midwest the west and Alaska right yeah
or you could tie it to um
this would actually bring water Valley
back into the equation but the economic
development zones
you're tired to average household income
in a given town
yeah through the ACs now average
household income would certainly help
Lincoln right
yeah
Woodstock yeah absolutely the property
values which screw you up
they go up but the income levels are
primarily low
yeah
where are you going to get that data
or the median income you only get it
from ACS
what is ACS we have that don't we the
census but
that's the American American Community
survey
um
and you know Doug Hall who's probably
done as much research as anybody
in New Hampshire on this
um has has talked about that how that
data is really not so reliable on a
granular basis throughout the state
that's why we don't that's why the
department doesn't rely on
so so
um are you really trying to get things
you know but are we so are we I'm trying
to figure out where we are here
um I'm trying to make this as simple as
possible
and I mean so the intent is to provide
this program for for teachers who'll be
teaching and underperforming schools you
have that data
um
and
um I'd say let's just use the term I
don't like the term but economically
disadvantaged communities
that would eliminate the
that would eliminate the Waterville
valleys of the world that are small
and wealthy
um are there is there another category
uh and and and also the issue of
um
those uh teaching areas that are in need
uh what's the term should I use not
critical shortage critical thank you
critical shortage teachers yeah
no you think critical shoulders if the
Chancery is that a rural no I'm not not
at all is that critical show is going to
be a third identifier yeah
I I might caution against using critical
shortages as a b or c
because then you could be faced with
Waterville Valley we've identified a
critical shortage in Math teachers what
are the value means a math teacher if
you're trying to you know using them as
an example
um then they would qualify so let's use
that as an example though
so let's say I have a teacher there and
they apply they apply for the
reimbursement for the loan
and the department would then determine
well no because
you may have this math teacher there but
we've got other other areas in the queue
that have a higher need
than Waterville valid
I'm I'm just trying to figure out how
the discretion discretionary from a
standpoint once the application gets to
the Department
and they make some determination of
whether or not this is a an appropriate
uh allocation of their loan
reimbursement
would that be a could that be a trigger
point too
or do you not want to have to make that
determination which I would understand I
I don't think anyone wants us to make
that determination I I think that the
the clearer this can be written so it's
fairly black and white because I I just
Envision a scenario where we're going to
have Educators complaining
what do you mean I don't qualify you
know and what I don't want to do is
create a situation is where we have
educator against educator
what was the first category you had read
there
uh that I'm trying right now I you know
when we were going through you started
over again what was the first category
that that was two minutes ago Rick you
think I can remember that
it's underperforming okay performing
right
just to mention that
um
so line six underperforming School based
on below average nape scores compared to
Statewide averages so not every school
takes nape every year yeah so that
may be an issue and you may want to look
at Statewide assessment scores or just
leave it at Statewide assessment
um just because of that with Nate not
all schools are taking that every year
and that's just going to be
at the fourth grade
and then I think again at eighth grade
so it's not
it's not like our Statewide assessment
system that's being administered
third through eighth every year
and then at 11th grade
you would say below an average Statewide
scores State yeah below average
Statewide assessment
averages and and removed nape scores
when we have to have this reported us is
it has an FN on it so that's an early
bill right no let's see it's 6 23. hold
on I'm just trying to figure out the
time we have to work
it's not an early bill
all right so um this is this is a this
has been valuable I think I need to sit
down with
with you guys and um
determine this a little bit more come
back with them uh yet another do we all
agree of underperforming is should be
part of the equation yeah yes do we all
agree property poor should be
part of the equation property core
community
it's gonna be pretty hard to attract
them if you don't have you know the
money to compete
and what about critical shortage
income
um
yeah I think so okay yeah probably four
versus income how about the critical
need thing I would think critical
shortage critical shortage because
you just wouldn't make it a determining
a b or c I would put critical shortage
elsewhere yeah to say it only applies to
loan forgiveness
in critical shortage areas or something
I mean we can come up with some language
um but I I wouldn't make it a
determinant of Eligibility so much as no
it's it's kind of below the line so to
speak because if you make a determine
then we're gonna you know Bedford needs
a math teacher
they're gonna you know and I don't think
that's the intent
right okay so this only applies to
critical shortage areas in locations
that are underperforming and property
poor
always out
well you're not going to be able to get
a loan for becoming an elementary
teacher right
you're going to get if you're science
math special education is that what
we're doing Steve
it'll be any critical shortage area yeah
any critical shortage area and it just
those are always on the list right other
ones others go on and off the list
Elementary goes on and off that's
correct we should we should also maybe
offline talk about what do we do for an
educator who starts in Pittsburgh
teaching Elementary edits on the
critical shortage list so they get the
first year second year we do the survey
it's off the list as a critical shortage
do they not get a reimbursement second
year or so we should probably think
through that scenario all right so this
has been hell for me this has been
Health let's stop this and I'll
I'll meet with Stephen
come back this has been helpful thank
you yeah we have a little time we have
to March 16th
oh plenty of time that's only a few
weeks away okay
thank you very much
okay let's go back up to uh 377
that's the relative to screening and
intervention public schools for dyslexia
and then when the policy is relative to
reading assessment and invention program
so that's what we have left in the
docket for today
377.
yeah
sure pass it around
here
foreign
okay
so this takes out the uh the reference
to divals as and it changes it to
evidence-based screener
um
takes out
enrollment in public kindergarten first
grade and approach appropriate times
thereafter to you know that whole
sentence to just entry to public school
the initial screening shall be completed
no later than 60 days of a student
entering a public school in kindergarten
through third grade
um and then repeated one additional time
during the current school year repeated
at a minimum of twice yearly through
third grade so
um through third grade was a big
difference
um if they fail to make the relevant
benchmarks uh then the school must
complete a secondary assessment within
30 days
and another important part of this bill
right from the start was that enter
enter some sort of interventions starts
evidence-based reading instruction
intervention or referral of the student
to special ed for further evaluation so
a lot of times when these students get
tested now from what I understand
there's a delay in the intervention
so one of the things that the author of
The spell wanted was to make sure that
that stayed and then
um you'll see that it refers to Charter
Schools as well in here so
kind of cleans up the bill a little bit
um
I know that that representative codelli
has tried to tried to put some of this
into his bill
um
but it really needs to be in my opinion
it needs to be a standalone because
dyslexia is so unique and also so
crippling if it isn't found out so what
does
cordelli's Bill number
I knew you were going to ask me that is
that the reading one it's the science of
reading Bill 137 437 okay I want to pull
that too
he does have an amendment for that
no his
his well his
name
question
those of you who have uh principal
experience and all I can probably answer
it best when I showed this to my wife
and my daughter my daughter says
teaching language pathologist my wife is
a former state director of special ed
they were both very enthusiastic about
this
they were very supportive of this
approach but they one question my wife
asked was what resources can a school
sort of assume it has or can get in
order to make that timely response that
you were talking about they were they
were keyed right in on that well I think
um
that the the state department of
education has put out uh some directives
on it there's actually this whole little
booklet called the resource guide for
dyslexic and other Related Disorders I I
was I saw that and I was wondering but
where's the funding coming if the school
doesn't have it where do they get the
well this is this is to give resources
to the to the teacher and uh um is
Corinne here if she's left
um she she was saying that she trains
um you know as a reading specialist she
trained people within the teaching just
regular teachers yeah and it and it
doesn't have to be I mean for dyslexia
it's just to realize that they don't
code things the way that everybody else
codes things and be able to start in
intervention to realize when instead of
keep pushing phonics or whatever whole
language to this kid to stop and say
okay he's got dyslexia so I now need to
do this and and elementary teachers have
had
training in this enough of that to where
they can be start intervention and then
work from there but as as representative
catawb said you know her her son got
tested and then it was like months
before they went you know got through
the Special Ed type uh screening well
and some people resist a special ed
identification that's true they resist
it yes so it doesn't have to be a
pull-out service it's something that can
be done in the classroom when they're
doing reading right right just to
realize that this yeah but then there
are cases I get and keep in mind I know
nothing about this is all what I'm told
uh but there are cases where you do need
a specialist most definitely most
definitely and that's that's what they
were concerned are the schools going to
have the resource to when they need to
have a specialist to get one right then
not later well they wouldn't get one
right then I'm I'm sure in the in the
poorer schools but they would this
department of education has a reading
specialist right that we're talking
about
um that they can use as a as a as a
um you know resource and they're both
very encouraged by this approach and
then I you know I know that as a teacher
when things pop up like this oftentimes
you can go online and you can get a lot
of great ideas right off the bat that so
and and I'm sure the special ed people
would be every school has you know
access to special ed so I'm sure that
would be it's hard to hear
what is general intervention
oh that's that's general education
intervention right versus the in-between
stuff that's going on here yeah that's
the general so what is it
well it's whatever it's whatever uh the
school has the resources the staff you
know if it's I mean at at Kearsarge when
I was there we had
a person who's who was a reading person
so definitely at that you know and at
the high school level it was kind of too
way way way way too late but
um I've in the district they had people
that were
reading Specialists so some of the
districts that are better off are going
to do that some of the some of the
districts that don't have all the
resources are going to have to you know
punt to get get some stuff but um I just
think some sort of General intervention
is better than none and and the sooner
the better
it it it's wonderful that they do it but
in those small districts
you know the classroom teachers got the
teacher of reading methods and all that
uh may be able to do something but what
happens if the parent walks and said you
know you're supposed to be doing you
know
in some kind of intervention here a
general education intervention what are
you doing that's significant to get my
kid going I don't want to see the
classroom teacher get hammered because
over a poor district and we you know
don't have the ability to pull some
reading support in like Haverhill just
did the other day when uh represent
cascadden came in and worked at the
middle school
um that's that's helpful but you know
some smaller just may not be able to do
that so do you think they're going to
get more hammered on that than they
would get hammered If the child was
dyslexia dyslexic and went a year or two
without any intervention or without or
even a month or you know even the three
months until the special ed uh it's I
mean is is some intervention better than
nothing absolutely okay and what you
what you need to do is work with those
Specialists that you know you may have a
speech pathologist available to you or
you might have somebody else's language
trained that's not necessarily in this
domain but has ways to help right
um but we can't pers I don't feel as
though we need to prescribe this just
neither would we prescribe I don't want
to prescribe it either special ed
services I mean that's all part of a
team at a school that's set up to deal
with that sort of thing and and I think
the the the
like I said I think the author of this
this bill Katie catawb would she really
you know she had a child that went
through this and what frustrated her
most was that he was tested and then it
was a couple months later until they
could get through the special ed
services before he got some services and
and like I said they do have the you
know the this is out of uh New Hampshire
Department of Education there's a whole
booklet can go to the parent to let them
know you know some interventions and
also uh the teacher so
yeah of course if a child is screamed is
in his dyslexic
does that automatically uh determine an
IEP for that is that is that is the IEP
part of this new intervention not the
screening not this you have to make a
formal referral through special ed and
the process starts Bingo all over again
yeah so so once a child is determined to
be dyslexia that then starts the whole
intervention process or I guess I'm not
well it's not sure Rick what you just
said dyslexia is not a specific
handicapping condition I don't believe
that was always our fight with Jack
Balcom do you remember yeah
and and so if they're seen as having
dyslexia
and it's determined that then the formal
intervention starts
and but what we're trying to say is what
are we going to do between the time
that's done through the screening that's
perceived that you've got dyslexia
to the time that special ed process is
complete that could be 60 days or easily
yeah and that's that's what you're
saying then they do all kinds of testing
and they won't just test for that
they'll do all kinds of testing
process you would if you would
identified
at the same time you've probably
initiate that referral just a six day
process you're talking about before
informal diagnosis there's days
associated with every bit of that
referral process from notifying the
parent getting it back getting the
testing set up there's all dates in
federal law for that right plus they'll
do a hearing screen they'll do a vision
screening to rule all of that out to us
it takes a long time so I think the
general and intervention you're talking
about or what classroom teachers do
normally in massage and benefits
children that have different coding
issues similar we've grouped them in in
that way so I think that is probably
what you're getting at with your general
integration strategies the only concern
that I would ever get into is
stabbing to get that done and any future
parents some of the implies you can do
it yeah
exclusive
helping resources are probably able to
do this once you don't
and they both have reading groups anyway
because not all kids enter School
reading I mean right at the same level
if you've been going to preschool for
three years you're entering differently
than the kids coming from home watching
TV yeah the first three years yeah
I think the other thing that she really
wanted was the notification the the
parent notification
um and I don't know why that might have
been delayed at a school but
um certainly the in line 27 it's this
the school show inform the students
parents their legal guardian and the
screening results
how possible would it be for a normal
school system would normal numbers of
kids that get diagnosed to have on hand
the books and the materials for any do
whatever reading program that they
decide on to just have it
available to them to use immediately
well dyslexia has been you know it
what was it three four years ago that
the first dyslexia bill came through
here and at that time it was something
that was recognized I mean it really
started people started recognizing the
issue a lot more than they ever had
before so I would assume and it's
terrible to assume I know but I would
assume that if a school district had had
one dyslexic kid come through then you
know they probably do have those
resources and somebody knows what to do
well you know what I mean you would
think you would think yes I guess that's
the part of assuming yeah
it's another type of training right
right right right
I think our department wants to help us
um so speaking as a department member
but also as a mom of a child who's
actually going through this process
right now
um not all interventions work for every
kid so dyslexia you may have a it covers
a pretty wide range of of a reading
disabilities so
a child can have an intervention and be
working with a reading specialist going
through that intervention and not making
adequate progress they might be making
some progress but not to where they need
to be so then it's like okay do we look
at
going through the special education
identification process do we look at
just using a different intervention that
might work for this student
the schools are a little bit
um
tied basically by the staff that they
have so if you have a staff member that
knows how to give a certain intervention
but that person is a special education
teacher funded with Federal special
education dollars right that has to be a
special education identified student in
order to receive that intervention
so you might have a reading specialist
that can do another intervention that
may not necessarily
um as might be just a reading specialist
but she's he or she is trained in that
they can deliver that intervention to
that student without having to go
through the identification process for
special education so there's some
different components okay to kind of be
aware of and the resources of that
school district and who is trained so if
I look at a child that maybe we could
just look at doing a different
intervention and see if progress
couldn't be made there and if that
doesn't work we might need to look at
another intervention or another program
I'm just wondering for a normal school
district what are they looking at and
how can they be prepared and what does
it cost
yeah
dependent upon the student yes
a wide variety The Language I I don't
know if I'm really keen on the word
intervention that place uh I think
during this time classroom accommodation
shall be initiated within 20
there have to be accommodations made uh
or modifications I guess either one of
those terms but accommodations you're
accommodating the needs of that student
through your how you're teaching and how
that child's reading and how that
child's learning uh in the classroom
um we might think of some other
when you talk intervention the
intervention process is one where you're
intervening to then look at and work
with others to try and figure out where
we have to go to help
and it oftentimes end up in special
education process intervention could
help end up with you're working with
community health or you're working with
bilingual education or or a number of
different Avenues maybe smaller groups
maybe intervention might let's talk to
the teacher you had last year and find
out what hearse his or her techniques
were that were so wonderful intervention
teams can make a whole lot of different
recommendations but what you're trying
to do is accommodate until such time
that you can get that special education
report done and in place
okay so you think if I
um amend this bill to wherever it says
intervention to you could say during
this time classroom accommodation shall
be initiated or or so so it's saying
something's got to be done okay
accommodation means you're tweaking
something okay
and and uh on
um
26 line 26 the intervention there is
okay
I would think you would want it to be an
evidence-based reading intervention okay
rather than
supplementary is fine supplementary
evidence-based reading instruction
intervention you would want it to be
26 I was looking at 26 yeah
you would want that to be
I would yeah I would think you'd want to
take out all that
um modified differentiated or
supplemental
take that out is that what you're taking
out oh no I'm just I would agree that
you would want to have the
evidence-based reading instruction
intervention you don't want to
modificate you don't want an
accommodation you don't want to so leave
the intervention there yeah thanks
yeah that's right yes
I want my kid to have an intervention
with an evidence-based program I don't
want her to be accommodated or I she
should be getting an intervention even
while she's waiting through the special
for the special education process to go
through she should continue to receive
that episode space intervention by I
would think of special yeah I totally
understand
and I did notice in comparing 377 and
there's some timelines where they
conflict one will say 30 days one says
60 days one
um says reading intervention is
immediately
um
given versus I think one of them says 21
days so we might just just something to
be aware of
between the two
because they both passed the new one be
hard to follow yeah which one do we do
so we Goodwood 377 sort of yeah do you
want me to make that to to send over for
an amendment well I think you yeah we
can we'll get closer and closer and
closer and we'll be there okay good um
so I think it's important what about
this 437 now
we have about
20 minutes left here
we have do you have Cornelius Amendment
is it all three two two uh oh four eight
five no
this has five pages
okay
we're gonna have to go get copies of it
I guess
but this one we have to get done so I'm
just I'm just going to look at that I
don't think it is
thank you
virtual engine here too yeah
I mean yeah if you want it yeah
Let's see we want this uh
seventh
four three seven it no we retained that
bill
so it's not a rush okay
I thought we retained check it out
I think they were just put on here
because of very similar
you don't have to do that no we don't
have to do it today
thank God
it's a fatigue oh yeah I think it's just
like feeling in the room
okay
so there's that's it for today right now
thank goodness there
the days are getting longer aren't they
there are the sun's up a little longer
but it's
only quite a chore here
I suppose they're going to be an in
person no we can go watch it
we also talked this morning about
um trying to get non-traditional people
to go to CTE programs like girls in
welding and reach out more too English
language
Learners yeah no I'm lights because
they're very unrepresented in those
programs
and that um what's her name is it Judith
Jennifer from um Pinkerton yeah said
they had a woman welding teacher for a
while and she said it's just the the
woman the girls in the program just
zoomed up and they had a woman in
Automotive
in the growth but when those people
leave the girls you know it's like
disappear yeah yeah there was a guy that
had a really nice welding business
yeah he said our children
watch out things are going
and she didn't buy it
the automotive deals
are you talking about Peter McMurray
anymore
they use an example of a 24 year old who
actually had no death when he got out of
school and actually has bought his own
home he doesn't have to be living with
his parents at 24.
because he went to the CTP Automotive
program yeah
a good selling point well it's like the
kid that's working over Kenworth here in
town
and he graduated under Steve
rothenberg's program at Concord went up
the White Mountain came back in charge
of Kenworth in terms of the technology
part of it and he walked back into 80
plus thousand dollars just walking in
the door
okay I need job yeah
um
yeah
the church
4 37.
I gotta get out of here